joe biden made an interesting comment
about how there is a liberal world order
and soon there will be a new world order
of course the media went nuts saying
it's all a big conspiracy theory ignore
this
nothing's happening he just means like
there's gonna be a new order to the
world okay which is basically what new
world order means to like everybody
that's the point but the interesting
thing about this is that he makes a
reference to generational change once
every three to four generations 60
million deaths between 19 what do you
say 1900 like 1946 or something like
that and so uh it very much sounds like
joe biden is anticipating the fourth
turning when he says there will be a new
world order so we're going to talk about
this what it means and what joe biden's
look i got to say joe biden's the
conspiracy theorist if joe biden is the
one saying there's a new world order
coming doesn't make him the conspiracy
theorist but sure whatever you say media
we've also got the daily wire jeremy
boring has unleashed jeremy's razors
because harry's razors cancelled on them
for you know they're doing ads for
harry's and then denounce their audience
so they are firing up with their own
grooming product and a subscription
service i suppose it is and it is uh
they released a commercial and it's one
of the funniest commercials i've seen so
we'll talk about that as well
plus a bunch of other news we've got
james o'keefe
has published uh
this is crazy that the biden's doj is
spying on project veritas spying on
these journalists going behind a judge's
back because a judge issued a special
ruling on a special master for veritas
so we're going to go into that the aclu
has actually issued a statement
criticizing this report
yet still denouncing project veritas so
i guess sure whatever so joining us to
talk about this and much much more is
emily joshinski how's it going do you
want to introduce yourself hey i am host
of federalist radio hour culture editor
at the federalist and director of the
national journalism center right on yeah
cool quick yeah that's quick and also
jack without uh jack posobik host of
human events daily turnpoint usa and
former nava intel officer and i'm sure
you'll be talking a lot about
both the judicial stuff and maybe touch
on ukraine as well oh definitely yeah
yeah you forgot to say you're a plaid
enthusiast um this is actually my first
plaid shirt i am
um now dabbling in plaid i've decided to
try it on i'm
coming out as as you know plaid curious
yes
live on the show is there green in that
place that's really brave there is no no
no it's actually an opportunity illusion
yeah it's actually no i think it's like
ladybugs
i never looked that
closely that actually is yeah it's
ladybugs we've had ladybugs in the house
this year yeah yeah they're everywhere
they're getting chickens actually
drinking ladybug juices yes
a little bit of healthy healthy i'm uh
coming down from coming back from a cold
i basically started to get a cold but if
you kill it right away because it's an
immunodeficiency it's a a rhinovirus
it's an immunodeficiency virus if you
get it before it infects your white
blood cells you can kind of just avoid
it
it seems like that happened yeah praise
the lord everybody thought because ian
was eating like
sludge yeah
i started getting aloe just pure aloe
fillet and then putting a little bit of
eternal reds in there but let me not
take any more time up ladies and
gentlemen ian crossland and of course we
have lydia over here yup i'm here as
well i'm not drinking any weird
squeezings tonight i'm just drinking
coconut water always a delight to have
one you're also not wearing yeah of
course i'm not you're right i'm not as
blind curious as jack is but uh jack is
rocking it so let's get going before we
get started head over to timcast.com if
you haven't done this already become a
member because that's what keeps
everything operating and we could really
use your support to help our journalists
stay employed and for us to keep doing
the show as a member you'll get access
to exclusive members only podcasts from
this show so we're gonna have one up
tonight around 11 p.m once we finish the
live show we record about half an hour
of this members only show it's a lot of
fun it's not very family friendly we
swear a lot just go to timcast.com and
in the top right corner you can sign up
and also if you would really like to
help out just smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
url to this live stream far and wide
all of you sharing this video if
everybody did it we'd be bigger than cnn
overnight at this point you know i've
been saying that for a while like we'll
be bigger than cnn now it's kind of
not that much of an accomplishment we'll
be ten times bigger than cnn yeah yeah
we'll be 10 times we'll be twice so uh
yeah share the video smash the like
button let's jump into this first story
from newsweek joe biden's new world
order comment jumped on by conspiracy
theorists okay let's just uh read a bit
about what joe biden said he said
as one of the top military people said
to me in a secure meeting the other day
okay can i just pause for a second
that is not what he
said no no no it's right there
the top military people in the secure
meeting about the nation the new world
right
but but i also i'm just talking to
hunter i i want to point out the two
crazy things
it's a it's a conspiracy theory and
biden literally prefaced this by saying
top military people in our secure
meeting said it but also why is biden
spilling secure meeting details to the
public like in a rambly i just imagine
that as he's talking there's like you
know kamala is just like and then you've
got like gensake and they're going no no
no no stop stop
anyway he said it's like we've discussed
the new ways to assassinate vladimir
putin
personalized bio weapon you see and you
know hillary on the shelf hillary was
there and she said can we just drone
this guy oh my gosh all right hold on
let's hear his quote here's what biden
said as one of the top military people
said to me in a secure meeting the other
day
60 million people died between 1900 and
1946 and since then we've established a
liberal world order and that hadn't
happened in a long while a lot of people
dying but nowhere near the chaos and now
is a time when things are shifting
there's going to be a new world order
out there and we've got to lead it and
we've got to unite the rest of the free
world in doing it
they then go on to say several people
online took biden using the phrase new
world order to confirm the existence of
the aforementioned conspiracy theory
here's what they do here's what the
media is doing
powerful world leaders like clinton
george h w bush even hillary clinton
they've all said there will be a new
world order
now for most people they think that
means there's going to be a global
system a judicial system or or legal
system because the council on foreign
relations publicly states that's what
their intention is with the liberal
world order they said after world war ii
to prevent war various you know powerful
institutions came together and creating
you know international organizations and
treaties to prevent this from ever
happening again and now there's going to
be a new version of that that's it
that's all it means so the media will
will push the most insane absurd version
of the conspiracy so they can try and
discredit what joe biden just outright
said that in a secure meeting he was
told this but but i think there's also
and and it's you know to go back to the
the headline of the show tonight there's
something even deeper that biden is
getting at because it's not just that
he's talking about setting up a new
version of the world order he's
essentially describing the fourth
turning so that means the president of
the united states just came out and said
that he was briefed by the top levels of
our military that we are in a fourth
turning is is that not what he just said
that's exactly look he didn't say
literally the fourth attorney but i
you're right that's essentially what
he's getting at right so you know the
only thing they're reading some strauss
howe and this he said four generations
that's that's too much it's obvious
they're watching tim castle
yeah yeah i think they actually some
people at the white house are because
when we were watching biden's campaign
speech it was the state of the union but
he didn't really get to say you know
called a campaign speech right um we
were like why are they so tight on biden
and then they they pulled out the camera
no i think they're watching and then
they point back in on his face thanks
guys well this is an administration that
is literally working right now on a
global minimum corporate tax right and
so it's not as though there's something
very literal happening when you say new
world order and that's why the
conversation about a new world order is
immensely frustrating because there's a
literal meaning to the term new world
order that has been explicit among
global leaders for forever and every
once in a while they slip up and say a
buzzword that's associated with
conspiracy theories but that's what's
frustrating about the dismissal of this
as a conspiracy theory is that like
listen we have an imf we have a world
bank we have a united nations we're
working on a global minimum tax right
now this stuff is pretty much out in the
open and when you have a slip from the
president united states like this even
from an administration that would avoid
sort of veering into that territory it's
extremely telling and it's not even as
though to the point about a fourth
turning that's not even in the biding
consciousness he's just talking about
what his job is it was just to be
friends with boris johnson and angela
merkel and all these people and to to
have the have control at their
fingertips well i think
i think i do think it's both though
because he talks about the 60 million
dying and that it's this cycle that
happens every three to four gen so the
preface of it is where he's talking
about the fourth turning and that this
leads to setting up a new version of
that someone might always have to say
rules based orders
who wants to read what website that is
what organization their website is the
world economic world
it's a world economic forum
can you pull up the article yeah here we
go so uh it's from the world economic
forum who wants to read who wants to
read the title
136 countries have agreed to a global
minimum tax rate here's what it means
that's great okay i like that so this
the world economic forum is citing
reuters but clearly you know the reason
i pull this up is the world economic
forum is very much interested in a lot
of this
global policy new world order stuff
the council on foreign you know what uh
let me let me do this let me let me uh
well let's read a little bit here
is the countries behind the global
minimum tax rate together account for
over 90 percent of the global economy so
that is to say
90 of the global economy are agreeing to
a global corporate minimum tax rate
which means they're agreeing to the
infrastructure to support and enforce a
global a global minimum tax rate so it's
not just that you can make this argument
that like listen if we were all in an
even playing field things would make
more sense economically no they're
creating an infrastructure to enforce a
global minimum tax rate right now check
this out this is the council on foreign
relations website news guard certified
100 out of 100
is it a conspiracy theory when the
council on foreign relations says what
is the liberal world order and they
literally say world leaders created a
series of international organizations
and agreements to promote global
cooperation on issues including security
trade health and monetary policy the us
has championed this system known as the
liberal world order for the past 75
years during this time the world has
enjoyed unprecedented peace and
prosperity i just got to pause real
quick especially
that was also very peaceful the bombing
of belgrade kicking the doors in iraq
was very peaceful rwanda peaceful rwanda
you know you know what you know what it
is they're
man it's it's it's very gen sakian it's
like
they're bragging about the thing they've
done but it's been an unmitigated
failure across the board but also it
doesn't exist right right they're
writing about it no no
so michael michael anton actually has a
great uh formulation for what this is
and he calls it the celebration parallax
and so the celebration parallax means
when they talk about it it is good and
laudatory but if anyone mentions it in a
critical sense not only are they wrong
but also the thing they're discussing
doesn't exist right
the new world
new world order is
amazing and just so great and i'm really
excited for klaus schwab and yeah all
that stuff it feels like now i can't
wait to not own anything because i'm
going to be so happy
but this is what's interesting is that
we lose and i wrote about this recently
that we have this nuclear order and
nuclear technology is literally younger
than some people walking this earth and
it is the most dramatic technological
advancement that has ever happened in
the history of humanity and it's
happened over the course of people's
lifetimes like it has happened that
quickly and we take for granted how
dramatically it changed the way that we
operate and so the new world order is
actually really new it's really new and
it's something that like when you have
all this technology at your fingertips
of course the leaders of the united
states of course the leaders of all of
these different countries are going to
want to have the power concentrated at
their fingertips because it's so
powerful and because they want they have
this sort of technological ability to do
it now that they can concentrate power
and rule over everyone because they're
terrified of what would happen if they
didn't what i'm wondering is are the
governments making concessions with
these corporations like they're like the
writing's on the wall the corporations
are taking over let's just intercede
with them instead of try and resist like
you said that they're all working
together to create a global tax rate
like is that
i i wonder if it's just like the
governments have given up and they're
like hey corporations are coming swaps
right corporate governments i totally
think so i think they're the same i mean
trump's first secretary of state was rex
tillerson like he was like literally the
ceo of exxon
and people it's like mind-boggling to me
that people forget that but it they're i
think they're basically the same at this
point i'd like to point out that uh the
council on foreign relations basically
describes the new world order conspiracy
theory as something that's already
happened
that's the that's the weird thing for 75
years for 75 years there has been a
liberal world economic order where a
liberal world order where world leaders
created a series of international
organizations and agreements promote
global cooperation issues including
security trade health and monetary
policy set it fast there you go anyway
the point is now that biden is like
every three to four generations
something changes basically saying we're
in the fourth turning and there's going
to be a new world order no longer the
liberal world order there'll be a new
world order well i don't understand why
they're acting like it's not a real
thing but it's also it what we are
actually seeing and the question is will
we will this trigger a thucydides trap
right um because and i believe it's the
economist that came out and dubbed what
we're starting to see the
just the sort of edges of right now are
or is an alternative world order and
this is the idea that because the u.s is
sanctioning russia so hard because the
us is now sanctioning ccp officials
they've threatened sanctions on india
well guess what you put those three
countries together that's over half the
world's population so they are going to
find a way to work together outside of
you and they're going to build their own
order in order to do so so the saudis of
course are already selling oil in um
in the yuan so they're getting away from
the petrodollar you might see a rise
they're already doing it yeah they're
discussing it right right um you're also
seeing uh india and russia are already
starting to trade in between their own
currencies they're not using u.s dollars
so that's the point of all of this is
because all of these transactions are
done at least certainly for oil and
energy at large are done in u.s backed
currency so that's the swift system so
the idea that the us dollar is just fiat
is actually i'm sorry crypto bros it's
not 100 correct because the us dollar is
essentially backed by something and
that's oil because of this artificial
demand for u.s dollars because of
foreign countries always needing to
convert into the u.s dollar that props
it up so it's not necessarily gold
backed it's sort of oil backed by this
global
i mean nothing's stopping any one of
these countries uh or world leaders from
switching off of the us dollar i mean
yeah
yeah
yeah gaddafi wanted to do it qaddafi
that worked out for him too yeah yeah
yeah yeah worked out really well for
them didn't it yeah a lot of guys can
just tell the us government like fu i'm
doing my country my own way and they
don't really care
and so they're all anti-nationalists
right like nationalism is terrible it is
intentionally conflated with white
nationalism unless it's ukrainians
fighting putin and then everyone that's
sort of in the neoliberal establishment
loves nationalism and celebrates it and
we see stories in the media on cnn of
these ukraine patriots who are you know
just carrying the banner of nationalism
which these same people think is so icky
here because it's about they see
themselves as citizens of the world um
and especially that's especially true of
the people like that doesn't mean you
can't be american but you see yourself
as a global citizen right they have
something literally called the global
citizen festival before your nationality
but you watch how quickly that flips
when the nationalists are in support of
their agenda right so cnn will you know
argue that somebody should be fired from
their job because they're cracking their
knuckles and it accidentally looks like
an okay symbol but an actual commander
of the azov battalion was just on cnn
yesterday who are an avowed um
far-right neo-nazi replete unit within
the u.s or within the ukrainian military
who was it who was uh straightening
their jacket before an interview stephen
miller stephen miller yeah and they said
it was a double double white power these
people are insane i can't imagine i
don't understand how anybody the same
people right to emily's point the same
people who will see nazis everywhere
behind every shadow here in the united
states when they're faced with an actual
group of avowed neo-nazis the boy who
cried we'll say oh no no no no no those
people they're fine because they're
fighting for something that we need to
fight i was researching the azov and i
look back it looks like the germans
after world war one took ukraine as like
a protectorate and then a bunch of uh
germans were there and then when world
war ii broke out a bunch of nazis were
there in western ukraine and started
like got really vicious and uh started
up as of i don't know much about it but
this is where i got to from there this
is why there's germans why there were
nazis in western ukraine is because it
was hold over from the wars
it's not so much that it was it's not so
much that it was a whole i mean
i think you have a half of it right it's
it's this idea and it wasn't as off
battalion back then it was this guy
steppen bandera who yeah
who so banderites and banderism um was a
arose because of this now it started off
as being an anti-soviet movement and a
pro-ukrainian nationalism movement kind
of like you were talking about but then
it went completely extreme very quickly
and even before the germans arrived in
world war ii they were essentially
declaring themselves on the side of the
germans because they were so anti-soviet
union so they start slaughtering
russians they start slaughtering poles
jews
if you basically if you were in that
area of western ukraine it's known as
west galatia or um excuse me east
galatia that you were basically not
ukrainian you were just completely wiped
out by this guy bandera but the previous
president of ukraine just recently
actually named him as a hero of ukraine
and a hero of the nation there's there's
statues to this guy that are up in their
in their city squares they must be torn
to the ground
there was a there was a photo of one of
the azov guys with the black sun i think
it was was that it mm-hmm
yeah right he was wearing like a
everything you see them everywhere i
think it was there was a reuters article
where they had someone who had the patch
on and they had to they actually blurred
it out wow oh that's the ss symbol shot
himmler himmler did that it's not a good
black song this is for i hadn't read
about it yet i know the symbol though
you know
we got a weird
whatever is going on in this country
where there are shows like this where
we're able to point out that ukraine has
staunch nationalists and you know overt
neo-nazi uh ideology yet the mainstream
media is cheering for it the antifa left
is now profa i guess you know
pro-fascist i mean it's so incredibly
offensive because they have no idea what
they've done to the co they actually
don't understand the fear that they've
instilled in normal working-class people
who for instance really like donald
trump and are afraid that they're going
to be called a nazi a literal nazi by
people at their office place by the
human resources department for tweeting
something in support of trump or
facebooking someone something in support
of trump and so it is just like to see
this it is so incredibly offensive
because they spent years seeing seeing
nazis everywhere i i have a question
though what would happen if
you if someone made
black sun buttons like pins but it was
yellow and blue like the ukrainian flag
and it said as of you know on the top
you can see that kleenox box is yellow
and black oh yeah look at that but do
you think do you think these leftists
would wear that yeah if you told them
like someone's a pro ukrainian symbol of
buttons
yeah they'd walk around wearing actual
actual nazi symbols oh yeah they
wouldn't care that'd be a good um that'd
be good like ryan long uh you know
segment to do right yeah it comes down
to emotion in that situation like are
they familiar with the symbol and does
it strike an emotional chord if it does
they'll stay away from it but if they
don't know they'll they'll collapse oh
hold on like so i'll ask you a couple of
different scenarios let's say you go to
union square in new york city and you
have these pins and you walk up to
someone say hey would you wear this in
support of the the the you know freedom
fighters in ukraine the as of battalion
it's the ukrainian flag they'll probably
say yes right
now what if you said would you wear this
in support of the as of battalion it's
the ukrainian flag and the nazis black
sun this is their symbol do you think
they would wear it then
yeah i still think that they would if
you said it was the nazi black suit
you think they would still do it i think
i think they would get a short circuit
but
it doesn't process right what's even
more interesting to me though is that
you know you go up to people who have
never heard of ukraine have never heard
of belarus you know maybe other than in
some like abstract discussion probably
can't find it on a map and yet are now
suddenly these experts on it and also it
becomes their entire identity just
overnight the same people who were you
know vaccine experts a couple of weeks
before
and prior to that they were
epidemiologists and before that they
were racism experts throughout all 920
and historians yeah and now they're and
now they're military members who are
saying you know these ridiculous
comments like oh you should just run up
and throw pain at the tank and that'll
you know that'll stop them and that
you're you know throw some water
balloons at it with you know filled with
paint my personal favorite crazy
craziness was when uh zielinski held up
the red salute and i said i didn't know
if he was supporting black lives matter
or communism it was meant to be like
tongue-in-cheek and i got a bunch of
responses where they're like you
wouldn't have you you're a coward you
don't have the balls to go to ukraine
and i was just like you know because
i've been there three times like well
you were there in the original coup i
was there i was yeah i was there in the
the start of the euro my dan protest for
several months and then i went back you
know a couple years later and you know
sort of followed up and did a little
video and stuff so yeah i was actually
there and i had you know guys around me
screaming at me and i was like american
journalist and they're like oh yeah yeah
you're cool now come on in dude it was
crazy we got to go inside a government
building that ransacked they'd like
stripped all the paperwork and pulled it
all out it was nuts crazy times man i
wasn't there when they when they started
throwing the fire bombs though what city
were you in thousand kevin
yeah this is the you know the
independent square they call it or
whatever euromaidan that's my dance
square square but they were calling it
euro maidan because they all wanted to
be in the eu
and the crazy thing is we went to a pro
yanakovic rally where everyone's waving
these flags and it was being reported in
british press as like so yanakovic just
for people who don't know yanukovych was
the current president at this time who
essentially blew up this economic
package for the eu that a lot of people
wanted him to sign you know they wanted
to sign this please do this who hired
tony podesta
to massage their messaging uh in the
senate with hillary clinton's state
department
oh yeah right yanakovich yes yes yes so
and they set it up through something
called the center for a modern uh the
european center for a modern ukraine to
try and get around feral laws uh because
it looked like they were just working
for this neutral think tank is the most
like beautifully corrupt is it's just
right and they're all the payments we're
like going through cyprus and yeah yeah
wow so yeah nico so it so the ukrainians
get all mad and very upset about this at
least in places like
kiev so they launched this massive
protest turns very violent but you also
had ukrainians who were still supporting
yanakovich and he had been at the time
the
democratically elected president of the
country so you did have these dueling
these dueling protests in the background
just to clear that up yanukovych was was
working with tony he hired tony podesta
yeah so he had a lobbying operation in
the united states that included paul
manafort who's working for mercury at
the time and tony podesta's podesta
group which is now defunct which is
amazing because it was one of the
biggest lobbying firms in dc one of the
most powerful lobbying firms in dc yeah
and it went corrupt i mean it went uh
defunct over this corruption because it
came out he was a casualty of the war
against trump the medias were against
trump um because they obviously caught
paul manafort on this and he was
convicted of violating pharaoh law but
it was amazing you can look at the
lobbying records of tony podesta's firm
meeting with people in hillary clinton's
state department as a representative for
the european center for modern ukraine
which he later admitted
he knew
was basically being was a front for
yanukovych so yanukovych wanted to join
the americans or did was he a russian i
thought he was a russian puppet well
that's what and jack could probably
explain this better but that goes
that has happened in different ways
depending on a time so if it's before
the eu the collapse of the eu deal it's
a different than if it was after what i
was told uh of course but since we're
talking about that you have to point out
mueller goes after manafort who had been
trump's campaign manager trump has to
fire manafort after all of this comes
out in like march of 16 or so um or
maybe later than that um they have this
thing called the black ledger which
turns out to be fake but supposedly by
made by um ukrainian operatives but
ended up you know they said it was the
like illegal payments to manafort but
throughout all of this manafort had been
doing it through the podesta group
podesta and tony podesta were given
immunity during all of this but manafort
has to go down for it interesting
i was told by some of the activists that
their view at least a lot of the
students and a lot of protesters was
that yanukovych was playing both sides
that he would you know well clearly
right so he was trying to get these
deals these sweet you know deals from
the from the west and then he would go
to russia and be like oh look what
they're gonna do for us and so people
were like the protesters wanted to be
part of the eu
being a part of the eu
this is their perspective
we could move to poland we could move to
the uk get jobs the economy is going to
immediately improve our lives will
immediately improve and that's one of
the reasons the eu is like hold on there
hold on there we'll figure it out but
the concern was ukraine's economy was
too weak
a lot of them were scared and also the
levels of corruption yeah right you need
to meet certain wickets and certain bars
before you can gain entry to the eu and
truthfully tell us what biden said biden
was saying you know corruption was a big
deal we were trying to weed out the
corruption it's just funny because i
don't trust him because he is corrupt i
got to know for myself i'm putting my
son on the board of baristas right yeah
this is an amazing again once we get our
money out of barisma then
when you start peeling back the layers
of the russia collusion hoax and you
find at the bottom here that tony
podesta is the brother of john podesta
hillary clinton's campaign chairman and
was taking money from yanukovych who you
you know playing both sides i think is a
fair way to say it and fled to russia by
the way after the collapse of that deal
and was protected by putin's government
when you peel back to that layer you
realize what [ __ ] this is
yanukovych hired tony podesta who was
running podesta group at the time yep
exactly and so he he hired podesta and
he hired manafort because that's how
lobbying works in dc um they need to
have a republican and a democrat
basically to get what they want done so
that they can massage both the
republicans and the democrats and it's a
that's why i always use this example of
one of the it's it's so perfectly
crystallizes corruption in dc so if the
if yanukovych was working with the
americans in the podesta group to become
with this american style thing then why
would podesta flee to russia
no i don't know where tony podesta is i
think he's in new york city i could be
wrong about that i think didn't he live
with the abramovich that woman weren't
they like friends
oh really cooking that like blood
cooking thing there's weird people she
did she did that famous uh uh the artist
is present do you ever see that i
actually saw it in person oh really
because i was visiting real real quick
though i don't know
she just sat in a room for like 30 days
is that what it was no it's like the
lobby of
the museum of moderation
and on like like the second floor lobby
but i was going at the time because they
had the tim burton exhibit um that was
only going to be there for a little bit
and it was sort of so tim burton opened
up his archives and you know everything
from edward scissorhands to beetlejuice
to like the batman costume the joker's
stuff um the
nightmare before christmas all the
little jack skellington heads and
everything and i was like oh that's
great tim burton let's you know we were
in new york i said we got to check this
out because it was only there for a
limited time
they had like a sand worm from
beetlejuice coming out of the ceiling it
was awesome but as we're going up we see
this this woman in all all red this red
dress just sitting in a chair and
there's this sort of roped area around
it and everybody's looking at her and
and you know
this is probably like
maybe 2010 or so and
you know i'm looking at it i was like
what's you know what's with the lady in
the in the chair why are people looking
at this oh no it's it's high art right
you're not sending their best like is
she gonna be drawing something does she
do caricatures like the people on the
street or something let me tell you it's
just this let me tell you what's
disconcerting what's this concerning to
me is that
people would come in and you could wait
in line to sit down in a chair like in
front of her right and there were people
who would like sit down and just easy
they'd start crying they would just
start like start crying and it's i'm
just like why are you crying you know
just people i don't know man
i really wonder sometimes about a lot of
people well i'm just going to say it
again for the 800th time in the past
week
every day we get a new story that's a
hoax
there's a uh we got the supreme court
hearings going on for um what's her name
kentucky jackson yeah yeah and uh
someone tweeted let me just remind
everybody that christine blasey ford
credibly accused brett kavanaugh and
republicans didn't care and i just see
that and i'm just like dude you guys you
lie about basically every major
political story non-stop all day every
day and then a month goes by and it gets
debunked so no i'm just you could come
out and you know point at the sky and
say there's a giant meteor i'm not
looking up just like the movie like this
no no no you're not gonna give me it's
it's it's the easiest motion in the
world to look up i won't do it screw you
you guys are liars i'll give you an
example today is the three year
anniversary of three years it's been of
the mueller report coming out and that
press conference that he gave
completely debunking the trump russia
collusion hoax wow three three years
since the debunking of the hoax is today
wow and yet you go to anybody on the
left or your your casual cnn msnbc
viewer they all believe it 100 well
they're bringing it back i mean it's
it's it's having actually a revival
which is really interesting you're
seeing a lot more people on the left
continuing to talk about it now because
it's their deflection point when they
talk about the abiding administration's
handling of ukraine they're like well
donald trump was in bed with putin's um
you're you're so we've been doing this
for years and you still
haven't understood you still haven't
reckoned with some disaster that that
happened so yeah that so it doesn't
matter nothing persuades them otherwise
they meant to solidify this sort of
you know government takeover that they
were pushing in ukraine bringing them
into the nato fold bringing them into
the security blanket
during the hillary clinton
administration right but of course the
hillary clinton administration never
took place and so they needed this place
holder to sort of keep that going keep
that energy going for throughout the
four years of trump and then that became
the trump russia collusion hoax then
finally after 2020 which is essentially
the same kind of domestic color
revolution that we were just talking
about the color revolution of maidan
you see those exact same uh tactics
being used here in the united states
right down to the violent riots and
cities um and then now that it then when
it ended suddenly ukraine and victoria
nuland the same exact person who was
behind so much of that in 2013 2014
comes right back in victoria newland
what's her connection with uh kolomoisky
i think they have a connection don't
they i'm into this kolomoisky guy we
talked a little bit about him before
though he's like a ukrainian billionaire
i don't know what you call him oligarch
he's like the puppet master or it looks
like to be let's jump over to some
domestic issues very important domestic
cultural issues that will shock the soul
we have the story from yahoo life ben
shapiro and jeremy boring of the daily
wire announced jeremy's razors campaign
against harry's if you guys haven't seen
this yet you've got to watch the best
the greatest commercial ever they
released in the daily wire and it's
legit really really good basically the
daily wire was uh sponsored by harry's
razors harry's razors got tweeted at by
a high school kid no joke like a person
who said i'm in high school and with two
followers and said you guys are bigots
so harry's was like we hereby denounce
the daily wire
so the daily wire has launched i hate
harrys.com and they've launched their
own jeremy's razors with this commercial
and it's brilliant not only is it funny
it's silly it's over the top he takes a
flamethrower to harry's and gillette
he goes after these companies who hate
you not not just terry's but also
gillette saying you know men are too
toxic or whatever and now the daily
wires launched their own male male
grooming products i think it's brilliant
for two reasons one the cultural issue
of it taking back the culture bringing
bringing back comedy
i'm looking at what the daily wire is
doing i'm seeing the way they're filming
things and i'm like this feels very much
like 20 20 2009 2010 vice
you know when it was when it was edgy
funny
over the top offensive when it was vice
when it was vice well and so the
interesting thing and i reported a year
ago that this was in the works and i
kind of figured maybe it wasn't going to
happen and i'm glad that it did happen
because it seems like a silly thing and
i remember when i reported it i was like
is this newsworthy but it absolutely is
when you think about it because what the
daily wire is doing is
creating this parallel infrastructure to
the so-called mainstream infrastructure
and there if you look at like gina
carano she gets purged from hollywood
she's a legit actress she gets purged
and the daily wire creates a soft
landing pad for her which then creates
more incentives for other people in
hollywood to be open about what they
think because they can land somewhere
when they get purged and somewhere
legitimate and so when you create this
parallel infrastructure you create real
competition to the the monopoly that
locaism has on corporate america and so
that i mean we talk about monopolies in
antitrust but this is like a an
ideological monopoly and there's no way
to create competition for it because
every single corporation is dominated by
this ideology and that's what they're
doing well it's it's similar to the
cancellation arbitrage that we were
literally just talking about with sort
of the new world order versus the
alternative world order because
sanctions on the international stage on
the domestic stage is cancellation and
so russia china india building up their
own parallel economy it actually kind of
mirrors what we're seeing happening
domestically with conservatives or just
sort of anti-woke companies and
economies of scale starting to be built
out and now supply chains
parallel social media everything from
rumble to
you know various social media platforms
that are being built out and it's it's
very similar how the mainstream is the
one that's kicking people out but
because you've kicked out now so many
people well that's enough to form a
critical mass where you can now build
your own structure in your system so
we're seeing it happening domestically
with things like this but we're also
seeing it happening
internationally i think's falling apart
are things breaking apart you know the
liberal world order this unified system
visa mastercard is being split here in
the united states the economy is being
split it might be a way to bypass uh
what's what would you call it where
there's when one superpower raises up
and then
there's maybe a way to binary
i don't know because when you look at
the way russia got economically
cancelled there's no way to strike back
when you're a military and then you get
cancelled by visa there's no country to
attack with your military it's all money
what could happen is starvation and then
people rise up against the starvation
like hey you can't starve us like this
then they take up arms and are called
villainized and then then that could
cause some sort of
conflict but i don't think it's gonna
get that extreme
because uh russia china and the united
states are capable of growing their own
food for the most part well not only
that but russia and china can direct i
mean they have a massive border with
each other they can directly trade they
don't or you know they have some in you
know talk about central asia they have
mutually beneficial countries that are
um that they have good relations with
that they can trade through so they
don't need to you know the united states
navy can't interdict trade between china
and russia so you know they don't need
us basically what we need in the united
states is more of what the daily wire is
doing yes oh yeah shaving products so
whenever you you know not only that but
daily wire has a streaming service
they're building up right i'm totally
jealous of the stuff these guys are
working on because
they're they're hitting the nail on that
with the hammer so we need to think
about woke companies that have us either
a monopoly or you know close to one and
then start actually making products yeah
so and one of the most interesting
things i've experienced in reporting on
the daily wires kind of ascent is
being on the set of tara on the prairie
which is the new gina karana movie
was fascinating because i was talking to
all of these people just from the crew
who have spent their careers in
hollywood and they're not sort of like
some of them are like red meat
conservatives but a lot of them aren't
they're just artists and finally i think
when you create again those landing pads
it's not just that top build uh talent
it's not just your gina karanos it was
makeup artists um it was people on the
crew and to a degree that i was really
surprised by who weren't just like oh
hey it's another job they were like no
no we're here because we're really
excited not to promote a conservative
message but to promote the message that
we're giving a middle finger to
hollywood and that's what artists need
to feel comfortable doing and the daily
wire is creating spaces for that and
it's it's going to be really really
powerful at least so far it seems like
it has been and the talent that they're
snatching up is also very interesting
yeah yeah the fascinating thing is i'm
watching the commercial and it's
remarkably well made in terms of
production quality
yeah it's just absolutely freaking over
we you want to roll that thing we
haven't been able to remember
it's like was it like three or four
minutes okay but he has a he has a
flamethrower that's you know i've done
um candace's show down there a couple of
times and just to talk about you know
the behind the scenes of that they have
a live studio audience yeah where they
do the show and the show is shot live to
tape and so you've got people that are
in there a couple hundred people per
episode that and everybody's you know
dressed very professionally dressed like
really really nice
um the audience is you know kept live
there's like an mc that kind of comes in
between when they're changing up the
sets i mean there's so much that goes on
behind the scenes there it's wild yeah
and their gift shop is one of the things
that sounds silly but that blew me away
because if you if you go to their gift
shop and they have one um outside the
set where they do candace's show
it's things that it's sort of like
inside daily wired jokes but you can see
how they're tapping into this really
kind of i don't know cultural populist
sentiment that uh i don't think anybody
else has come close to doing yet i have
always loved the jokes they've had on
this show it's always been a running
joke that ben is gonna fire michael
knowles it's always been a running joke
that matt is a cranky old crab he's an
old coo he's not even that old but he's
just that's his persona they come up
with these personas they're very
personable they're very funny they get
along with each other they smoke cigars
together i think it's awesome so harry's
this is this is interesting i'm you know
i don't know of any companies that have
co-ceos that's like a normal thing
because the daily wires like a joint
venture co-ceo yeah but the uh we have a
statement here from jeff raider they say
co-founder and co-ceo of harry's he
states we created harry's to offer
better shaving and grooming products for
everyone we believe deeply in free
speech but draw the line at hate we'll
continue to support our customers and
community with kindness and compassion a
spokesperson from the brand continued by
saying that harry's does advertise
across the various media including the
conservative fox news however the brand
is not associated with entities that
engage in or endorse hate speech
um ladies and gentlemen
if you have a hairy subscription you
should cancel it and get a jeremy
subscription yeah right because you know
here's here's the challenge with netflix
and disney if you want to watch the
latest disney movie it's disney or
nothing baby if you want to watch those
netflix series it's netflix or nothing
if you want to shave your face it's
harry's or jeremy's yeah and jeremy is
the company who are like we don't hate
you we just want your money and harry's
at the company and says we actually do
hate some of you yeah we hate you
because you hate so we're gonna hate you
and
there's there's another really
interesting and i think uh dark element
to this which is and the example i
always use is like why on earth is
stephen colbert um one of the most and
often on the ratings the most popular
host in late night and we can talk about
greg gudfeld which i think is another
amazing story but stephen colbert he is
objectively the worst comedian in late
night and he's also the most partisan
comedian in late night which just
completely flips the script you used to
have johnny carson's writers sit down
every night and ask themselves the
question what is going to make america
laugh tonight stephen colbert's writers
sit down every night and think what is
what is going to make resistance boomers
laugh tonight and he wins because he has
cornered that niche audience and he has
built this loyal following among that
niche because no longer do you need 15
million viewers to be the king of late
night you need a reliable three to four
million viewers to be the king of late
night and this happens with the death of
mass media and the death of popular
culture in different sections of the
economy and that's why harry's razors is
going to feel more comfortable they want
to be the razors for progressives it's
like the dumb gillette commercial but
but look
i think what colbert realized in a lot
of a lot of these hosts is that you're
not going to get a general market
anymore exactly so they've abandoned the
idea yes and that's that's hyper
polarization it's very scary to me i was
just watching it it's smart on a
business level but not on a cultural
level it's terrifying i was watching
johnny
starting tomorrow everybody on the show
has to wear maga hats with trump
this dialogue last night watching johnny
johnny carson and what i was watching
was the drew carey his first appearance
on carson 91 and johnny is so was such a
loving host
like his favorite thing to do is show
new talent to the world right but it was
all centralized at that time in the in
the early 90s 80s before the internet
there weren't a million comedians now
there's like a million there's like a
hundred thousand or ten ten thousand so
you can't there's no like
funnel to hose them through it's a
completely different environment the
fact that that show still exists is
insane yeah it's it's the wrong format
a wild man it doesn't make and he wasn't
apolitical by the way he told political
jokes but they were jokes that everybody
could laugh at let me i wanna
my take on this is that a lot of people
pointed out that we do have this sort of
um
breakup of central pop culture and
certainly breakup of media but it there
have been times in america's history
where we've had
uh
huge flourishings of alternate
viewpoints if you go back to the
founding and you look at the printing
press if you look in the 1900s at the
level of the amount of newspapers each
city used to have
this idea that all media has to be
centralized and that everybody has to
can only watch you know three six and
ten and there's only a couple of
networks that was just one moment in
american history and it's certainly not
the it
talk radio has been around yeah we
really do yeah talk radio has been was
around prior to world war ii right but
then you need you need institutions like
the new york times to stop pretending
they represent or they're reporting on
the entire country let me show you where
this is headed
i found this article from march 4th
today from defector it's titled i
watched a ben shapiro movie by accident
how do you watch how do you go to the
daily wire by accident sure or whatever
but they write quote if you're looking
for something to watch shut-in is pretty
fun and vincent gallo gets his ass
kicked if you're in that sort of thing
that's a tweet i wrote a couple weeks
ago late on saturday night it no longer
exists the reason it doesn't exist is
because almost immediately after i
posted it i got a dm from a friend uh
you know that movie was produced by the
ultra right wing daily wire
with only ultra right wing producers
talent and so forth for that market uh
what no no delete delete what yep
they're trying to make real movies now
sneak that ish and under the actual
cover of actual production values for
f's sake this always happens to me it
always happens to you huh i will be
watching an ultra evangelical movie and
not realize it's ultra evangelical i
will be listening to christian radio and
not realize it's christian radio if
jesus is around i need him to announce
himself or i'll just think he's from
brooklyn
i'm sorry brooklyn that's hilarious
here's the funny thing how do you
accidentally listen to ultra christian
radio and be like wait
are these are these biblical topics
christian
who is this person who's like i actually
look what they're saying they're saying
i enjoy conservative content i enjoy
these movies i enjoy christian radio oh
no i'm not supposed to delete delete
delete yeah that's how you know you're
dealing with a cult right exactly they
like typical cult behavior it's a cult
man you know i watch disney i i went and
i went i saw ghostbusters 2016. i
regretted it but i'll go see those
movies and then i went and saw the new
ghost news ghostbusters i liked it
i watch uh uh i read the daily wire you
know i check out
the stuff they're producing or whoever
because i'm like oh someone can make
something good it's good i'm now getting
to the point where i'm like get away
from these companies that hate you and
want to take your money for bad things
but maybe that's kind of the mentality
they've always had and and the you know
libertarian civil libertarian or
conservative side is only just now
realizing it for the longest time
conservatives have been content to give
their money to people who hate them and
the left has always been against giving
their money to people who hate them i
don't think conservatives realized how
much these people hated them because i
don't think they realized what was
brewing
in the sort of academic on the fringes
of the academic left which was this
thing that i've called the progressive
or bigot binary which is that you are
either necessarily progressive or a
bigot so if you are not fully
progressive at every turn and you don't
agree with every little tenet of our
idea or our faith i should say then you
are a bigot if you fall just outside of
that you're a bigot and when you enforce
that i just don't think a lot of
conservatives realized that this is what
was building that like if you disagree
with them um if if you disagree with
them at all it's not just that you think
clarence thomas is innocent because it's
the early 90s now it's if you think
brett kavanaugh is innocent you are
responsible um for being you're
complicit in rape um and you have uh you
you have created violence against women
i don't you know i just i don't care
about what these people think
in terms you know to a certain degree
because because of things stories like
this right it's it's it's just what we
we've the country's bifurcated the there
was a there was a period where we had a
culture war i think the culture is just
totally bifurcated like a thousand times
over and over and over and over and over
well i mean pockets of weirdness when
when we started when the culture war
first began depending on what you think
is the first great moment in it it could
be occupy wall street because that's
where i think the issue is most people
didn't see the wokeness in the
organization of occupy yes but gamergate
was pronounced widespread on the
internet and was bubbling up and
creating these personalities who were
you know always viewed themselves as
being on the left but now viewed
themselves as being called right wing
at that time
we were still very much interested in a
lot of the same things just disagreeing
on them now we're at a point where it's
like you guys go make your the craft
remake which is just a woke psa and ben
shapiro and the daily wire will make
regular movies that we'll watch
right and that's the thing that ben
shapiro and the daily wire get is that
they need to make regular movies and
that has not happened before that's the
big difference between what they're
doing and all of the other so-called
conservative art that's come before them
i've got a lot of friends on facebook
from the old days when i was a
progressive bigot like you're saying i
was like oh they don't they don't they
want me to whatever okay um they're like
now they're they're talking about
serving other people this new the show
with celinski is the the lead right and
they're like oh i hear this show's okay
i can't wait to see it yeah man i loved
it i'm definitely watching this and i
know what i got queued up
netflix just put back on
in the midst of the ukraine war netflix
just brought servant of the people which
is zelinski's is it was a sitcom where
he played the president of ukraine uh
back in 2015 then he ran and actually
became the president of ukraine so
netflix us has now put netflix put this
back on netflix in english i feel like
they're watching it because ukraine got
invaded it's pure call oh yeah yeah yeah
it's it's ridiculous
i mean it's just obvious you go on
facebook and i see all these people
their their profiles are ukraine flags
now they're posting memes they're
they're saying like things about
zolensky people are saying like cuomo's
out zelinski's in or whatever and i'm
just like oh gosh you guys have no idea
what you're talking about you're
literally in a cult and you know why you
know it's this simple
you ask someone what do you think about
ukraine a not cult member says you know
i've heard about in the news honestly
i'm not not real you know following
following it i don't like the war so
russia sucks for invading but i wouldn't
know a whole lot what do you think about
zelinski who's that he's the president
of ukraine oh no idea the cult members
are like yes yes ukraine flag and i'm
like why do you support ukraine because
big country invaded small country
the president is a comedian yeah and
that's all they need mm-hmm
i think there are people and then
and i love ian because he's like hey
who's this guy igor kolomoisky who seems
to be funding all of these things oh
yeah so kolomoisky started a tv
started funding them as private security
battalions for himself and his own
militia he was a governor at one point
we've all done that no we have we have
um
and uh and you know but we're not
supposed to ask questions about
kolomoisky no no no no no this is you
know
a liberal democracy that we all love
what about all those corruption reports
and hunter biden and barisma and all
this money and the podestas and manafort
and all of these things you know isn't
this like a human trafficking area
hasn't this been known for it obviously
we don't want it to be corrupt we would
like it to be you know a stable country
but you know what about all of this you
know reporting in fact dude the call of
moisty thing okay so he started serving
the people the tv show or he he said he
had he ran or owned the network the
network that ran this show and then he
hired zalinski to be that role and then
he started a political party called the
servant of the people
named after the show and then he got
zielinski to be the his candidate that's
the most ian transparent fascist crazy
his vision we'll call it call it
whatever you want i'll take it but this
this should be an example to everyone
listening why it's so important to build
culture why it's so important to make tv
shows make cartoons make jokes freedom
tunes has a new cartoon out today
i did the voice of doc it was a lot of
work we took like half an hour to record
this but uh if you guys aren't familiar
with shamus on the show periodically
this is humor it's making fun of dr
fauci so the the joke that i don't want
you know you got to watch it but the
general idea is dr fauci hasn't been on
tv in months or a month or plus since
everyone pivoted over to ukraine from
kovid so the joke is he keeps calling
like hello is anybody there like why
won't you answer your phone
we're making fun of what the
establishment props up what all the cult
members when they're all waving their
flags and claiming you know all these
things and saying how much they love
fauci or when uh stephen colbert had the
dancing syringes or whatever whatever he
did yeah or who was it who did the thing
where they spun up from there's like a
camera angle going up this was jimmy
kimmel no no it was courting
so like we make fun of that that gives
people a space they feel like they're
not alone but also going back to what
you were saying before with the daily
wire and and creating movies it's
showing all of these people who don't
like what's happening in their workplace
there is another place you can work i'll
tell you that in in addition to making
art that shows how ridiculous things are
you can make art like i can make a show
where you become the president and in
the show you're a hero and people love
you and you save the world and if that
people that becomes a popular enough
show people will want you to be the
president you know why they made men in
black right
no not no yeah you guys know the movie
men in black of course yeah great the
government made that man wasn't alien
when you try and prove that that men and
black are real no one believes you
because it's it's a movie man yeah no
that's that's that's that's an actual
conspiracy with the x-files too
there's actually a conspiracy theory
that the government funds movies so that
when you want to talk to someone about
the conspiracy theory they say that's a
movie dude what are you talking about
well so they do fund more movies than
people realize um the actually in in
fact the new uh top gun movie where the
it kind of made headlines because the
bomber jacket mavericks bomber jacket
had the taiwanese taiwanese flag and the
japanese flag taken off well it turns
out actually and if you really dig into
this the pentagon it sounds like a
conspiracy theory it isn't um actually
provided a lot of resources to that
movie and they used training drills
actually to be scenes in the movies so
it works out great for hollywood and it
works out great for the pentagon because
they want to have the u.s military look
good and all that stuff but what it
means is that our government resources
were complicit in moving the removing
the taiwanese flag from the bomber
jacket and it creates this ridiculous
cycle
but they absolute the pentagon
absolutely provides resources and what
you could clearly say is x amount of
dollars to these movies when you guys
were saying how we centralize stuff
three five and eight the three channels
you know it's very new it's very like we
have the printing press then also we
have tv and we have the same
just tv itself and radio it's got to be
mind controlling us like crazy it's so
new in our species evolution well so
what's wild is that like
and not not to delve too into ukraine
specifically but you look at the
reporting of it how many of the stories
that we see initially come out of
ukraine and then it goes 24 to 48 hours
and it's completely debunked right right
and that's because we have the system
that we have now
but
prior to this did we have anybody going
you know how could you right how could
you go to the newspaper and understand
what was going on in world war ii
right because you weren't on the ground
we didn't have this sort of
instantaneous communication system like
we do now where we can communicate with
somebody in ukraine in russia in belarus
in poland literally in real time to
understand what's actually happening and
so we're getting these reports and this
is how people like walter durrante for
the new york times were able to
completely cover up things like the
holiday war
like people like edgar snow in in china
were able to talk about the chinese
cultural revolution and the chinese
great famine as if oh no they weren't
happening is this wonderful thing it's
chinese communism right because you
didn't have somebody do that so the
question then becomes if that's what's
happening in ukraine and we can see
right we can see this stuff being
debunked everything almost within 24 to
48 hours or at least the initial frame
is always kind of like slightly
different like oh they hit a you know
they hit a shopping mall oh wait but
there were tanks operating out of that
shopping mall and missile launchers
right um so it you know
you have to put it in a different
context
then what does that mean for the rest of
history his story dude his story some
dude wrote it story yeah i don't buy it
right i don't believe any of it the
bible uh it's all his story man there's
this uh
well the
back in the day when i was a little kid
called bathroom readers you ever hear of
them
they're big books that you were supposed
to buy full of trivia and you just like
put in your bathroom oh yeah yeah i only
on the on the bottom of every page was a
factoid and that's what i mostly enjoyed
reading but there's a story in one of
them about how there's this great
painting of american revolutionary
soldiers chasing off a bunch of fumbling
stumbling regulars
and they say that the original painting
was fumbling stumbling
a revolutionary you know uh continental
army fleeing a well-regulated you know
british regulars and then every time the
the painting got recommissioned or the
story was retold it became more and more
lopsided in favor of the the us
because you know people were then five
years out from what actually happened
then 10 years out right and so someone
would tell the story of this battle and
it would get embellished a little bit
and then eventually
american patriotism they're going to be
like the americans they fought hard and
they chased away those spineless cowards
and then you get this image that's
totally unrealistic uh napoleon was
great at that he had paintings
commissioned of all his officers his top
ones and make them all look beautiful
and like you know they're not that they
weren't but they weren't those in
photography so my take on this is that
um when you look at like instagram
culture now and filters and you know
photoshopping and face app and all of
that that's just that's just what humans
have been doing for years but only the
elites could actually afford it so
whoever was commissioning the sculpture
right with the emperor of rome well of
course they're going to say you know
you're going to make me look like this
perfectly chiseled you know features and
everything or the pharaoh or the king or
whatever aristocrat it was um but then
like the first english queen that we
actually have photos of i think is queen
victoria so look at a photo of pink
victoria next to the painting of queen
victoria and you're like hey wait a
second what would donald trump say about
queen victoria right oh i don't know
what what's her thing
no
seeing if you present donald trump with
a picture of queen victoria
how does he react
no all right let's let's i don't think
you'd be into it let's just want to see
him there's a bunch of stories we can
choose i'm choosing this one because
sometimes we need a little innate
innanity in hannity yeah this is from
fox news nicole hannah jones goes off on
tipping as a legacy of slavery deletes
the tweet hannah jones clashed with
historian phil magnus over the history
of tipping well so here's what happened
right everything is slavery turned out
well hopefully you can also just stop at
nicole hannah jones clashes with
historian there's there's two two big
things happened which yeah that's
actually kind of two big things happened
from her tweet from within the crit
community within the woke community one
was that she's right and the other was
that she's racist so let me read what
you said first she said tipping is a
legacy of slavery and if it's not
optional then it shouldn't be a tip but
simply included in the bill have you
ever stopped to think why we tip like
why tipping is a practice in the u.s and
almost nowhere else actually tipping is
widely practiced all over the world but
uh what some people immediately said
it's not huge in asia it's not huge in
asia europe well it it actually it was
offensive in in asia in asia it's
considered like a bribe almost well so
uh in some countries the way we would
consider a brand when when you have bad
service you put extra money down saying
you need help do better like you need
you need my charity because your
business is doing bad so it's considered
like on a front to their honor like they
they told you what it cost for their
service they provided you a service to
give them more is to imply they're not
doing well and they need help but uh
it's it's kind of changing in a lot of
the or that they work why are more to
give you a higher level of help right in
the in the west it's like demanded
anyway but here's what happened first
many people agreed with her they were
like
you know the stereotype is that you know
black people don't tip well or whatever
and her that that's what they were
pointing out like her point is you
making someone give money for a bad tip
is racist and that's where the
stereotype i don't know if you said this
but explicitly but people were saying
the stereotype is that people who are
black experience bad service because of
racism
that's why they don't i see that's why
there's a stereotype about not tipping
is because they're mistreated for being
black other people said you're literally
reinforcing a stereotype about about you
know these diners so my point in all
this is honestly i have no idea
i have no opinion because i've not been
a server or experienced yet i can just
say no matter what you do it's racist
even when you're nicole hannah jones she
she's the 16-19 project right yeah yeah
even she's racist so there's no out all
of you everyone at all times even the
person who claims everyone else's race
is racist too and so uh i don't know
what the aristocrats or something well
tim you're obviously the wrong person to
talk about this i mean you're so bad at
diners you can't even get a reservation
at one yeah how come you didn't get a
reservation for that diner anyway it's
so crazy right yeah i guess you can't
isn't it the weirdest thing in the world
to me dude i was aware is the weirdest
thing in the world it is to me i was a
waiter for about a decade on and off
what about what about you emily were you
over no i was a camp counselor
i worked at a bakery so like bakery
slash deli so we served food but it
wasn't like with seating we did the tip
seating everything i yeah i had one time
i had a couple of older women left me a
nickel just so i knew that they didn't
forget to tip me
that was insulting that was when it was
early and there was a there's an old uh
30 rock episode where i forget the
character's name but um and it's john
lithgow's character and he goes he goes
i'm going to revolutionize the the
practice of tipping i always thought
this was great where he goes and he he
the weight the weight i think it's a
wager is think she comes down and he go
he just plops a stack of ones on the
table and he goes do you see this right
here this represents your potential tip
now
if this
if the surface is good the tip will grow
but if it is poor the tip will shrink
the final number is up to you wow you
make it a game show it was great yeah i
thought it was great a lot of waiters
and waiters i've always thought of
actually doing it they didn't they too
i'm pretty sure you're by the way if you
try that in real life i'm pretty sure
your food would get spat in very quickly
nope not everybody you know 100 bill or
you know 10 hundreds on the table and
say i got a thousand bucks you know or
however many
ready and waiting for you
as the service declines the hundreds get
removed so let's see how much you can
make at the end of the day i don't think
they'll spit in your food i'll cheat
code for flights tip your weight uh tip
your uh services
okay first come on totally um go to the
starbucks get like
10 gift card 15 gift card right there in
you know why you're while you're waiting
to get out in the terminal just walk on
even if you only give it to one right
they'll tell the others and they they
know where you are right and i i
guarantee you you're playing your flight
and when you go to the bar tip the
bartender before you start ordering
drinks yeah because then they love you
all day what do you think would happen
if you were sitting on a plane and like
this the flight tenant came over and
said sir i'm sorry you have to wear a
mask you just handed her a hundred
dollar bill instead
and they're like oh i'm sorry here you
go and like you know i'm sorry they need
to wear your mask right when i was
waiting tables uh i george washington a
lot of other a lot of other servers
would have been frank this thing you're
saying that black families were would
not tip well and i hated it and so i did
a stereotype yeah i one time i had like
a family of like five or something i
think i'm remembering this relatively
clearly and they're black people i don't
even think no no their skin was like
darker than mine whatever the hell that
means i'm not white by the way uh i'm
pink uh some of these people i was like
i don't care i'm not playing this game i
gave them the best service i could and
they didn't leave me a good tip it was
really bad and i just thought they
didn't have enough money i didn't care
it wasn't racist i don't care you know
if you can't afford it you can't afford
it you pay it's a tip it's extra it's
not meant you know yep my issue is
that you get money on the left saying if
you can't afford to tip you can't afford
to go out to eat
and then i'm just like you know i was
thinking about that and i was like if
you can't afford an electric car you
can't afford a drive
right so all the environmentalists who
are like gas is destroying the planet
that's my response to them you know look
climate change is bad
if you want to enact policies over
climate change then you got to put up or
shut up so don't come to me and be like
we got to change the wages because you
know if you can't afford a tip and i'm
like okay well then like don't come to
me and say you have a problem with
carbon emissions when you're literally a
component of the problem
choose not to be a part of that problem
there's no coherence when i was in ohio
waiting tables i was making two dollars
and 13 cents an hour
minimum that was the minimum server wage
because you expect to get tips because
you're supposed to get it's woven into
the process now so we can undo that but
then went to california i got minimum
wage 12 bucks an hour and then tips on
top of it that's a california law
um
i guess we could
no i just they're they they super chat
the daily wire wrote about me we're
making a big circle
absolutely fantastic brilliant one of
the funniest commercials i think you
might have actually said all that stuff
yeah i did say all that stuff yeah here
here i suck at the daily wireless i
haven't seen the commercial i was
talking to some of this another glass so
now they're going to write an article
tim poole raves about the taylor wires
of the daily watch
and here's media bias in a nutshell what
is the byline there the author of the
story his name is tim they know
tim okay
i gotta i gotta wonder hold on
i'm wondering if like uh jeremy or
banner or somebody the daily wire saw my
video this morning and then came in and
said can someone write this up because
it's free advertising for us so let's
just shout it out
yeah or or maybe this tim mead's guy was
like hey did you see tim did a video can
i write this up and they were like
yeah i will groom with that thing on air
if you sent me one yeah let's do it
groom with uh well jeremy's racist
yeah
shave just sounds like some q a
stuff don't don't well but but if if and
if you get caught hopefully you get uh
judge kataji brown jackson
she'll give you a lighter a lighter
sentence emily you've been following so
you think she's legitimate katanji brown
yeah uh would define legitimate well do
you support her for supreme court no no
no no no no no no i mean i think she's
an activist um i think she's an activist
judge um and you know it's a it's an
interesting question because the senate
sort of caught in this period where
there used to be courtesy
um votes in favor of a president's
nominee right and then they got away
from that and so now you still have the
people like the mitt romneys of the
world and the lindsey grahams of the
world and the susan collins of the world
who think you know if somebody's
qualified we give them the courtesy vote
they're the president's choice etc etc
but nobody on the left or the right i
mean that's that's a minority position
on the left or the right and the left
and the right will pretend that's the
consensus position um in when it is
favorable to them but this is a case
where you have very much an activist
judge and you have this this questioning
process it's sort of a given that she's
going to be confirmed
but the questioning process is being
treated as though in in a number of
different ways like i sat down with
marsha blackburn last week and i said to
her there is a 100 chance that next week
you are going to be called a racist it
is inevitable that whatever you say in
your questioning you are going to be
called a racist how do you respond to
that is it time for republicans and i
actually mentioned ron desantis to start
flipping these questions to start um
changing the narrative and to stop
accepting the premises of these
questions
and i think we see a little bit of
grappling with that on the right you
definitely see it in desantis you
definitely see it with trump but i'm not
sure that everyone has fully gotten to
it because when you look at what
happened with the kavanaugh confirmation
hearing as has been invoked by many
senators just in the early days of uh
judge brown jackson judge brown
jackson's confirmation hearing it's
night and day i mean it's incredible how
you have dick durbin coming out and
saying some of the questions to judge
jackson have been uh you know teetering
near the line i was like what the hell
were you guys doing with kavanaugh then
what were you doing questioning amy
coney barrett's faith what were you
doing um what was the media doing when
they were talking about whether she
might be a racist because even makes
candy best-selling author even mike's
candy extremely powerful author and
commentator even max kennedy comparing
her to a white colonizer because she
adopted black children a little bit a
little bit close to the line there dick
i was speaking at an event and uh we had
it we we opened up for questions and uh
stixx hex and hammer was
you know coming in via zoom or what
wasn't it without a skype or whatever
back then and someone asked a question
about defending an individual for
something they had said and the
individual was like a white nationalist
something so it felt kind of like a woke
journalist tee up to write about
and uh as soon as it came up i was like
are you referring to that guy who's you
know who has been reported to be a white
nationalist is that what you're trying
to ask about and then sticks immediately
came in and he said we shouldn't dismiss
people based on opinions that aren't
relevant to the conversation we should
answer to the the topic that's being
brought up before us so we can actually
question the idea you know we can't fall
into that trap of someone being a bad
person and all of a sudden the idea they
present is dismissed outright because
the person said it's bad anybody could
have an idea like two plus two is four
you know what do they say hitler had a
dog too right and i just thought that
was an excellent response so you know
bring this up when we're looking at
what's happening with uh
the media trying to accuse you or smear
you as being racist it's just you have
to completely disregard it as unserious
and irrelevant but the problem i think
we have is that many republicans care
more about the opinion of the new york
times and their own constitution yeah
they still do and that's what's that is
what is confounding and so yeah no i was
just gonna say so
you've seen senator hawley right who's
really done the work you know that's the
new phrase right now do the work um he's
actually done the work of digging up her
record on these lighter than required
sentences rather than later than
suggested sentences for child porn
offenders and child porn distribution we
should probably talk about this issue
because she's bringing up you know
saying well it's different now these
laws were written uh during a time of
child pornography distribution by mail
and so it was harder to accumulate
this many uh this such a large volume of
it and so because of each instance of
possessing an item of child you know
child pornography then it beca it meant
that that person was a more serious
offender but because of the internet now
it is easier to accumulate large volumes
and so it created what she called a
disparity in the system whereas you know
i think most normal people looking at
that would say
well doesn't that just mean it's easier
to victimize children so right probably
be harder against it because it's so
much easier to victimize children with
child porn other than when it was in the
past and you had to do this very
surreptitiously um and it also strikes
me to that point as what you just said
that that's a very activist argument
right if you don't like it it's a lot of
things to be an activist for to be
completely honest
right you know isn't that isn't that
that thing you know you know if somebody
keeps talking about it then they you
know we have to ask questions about why
they keep talking about well why is this
the one thing that she seems to be such
an activist for you know uh apologizing
i'm so sorry that you're gonna feel
shunned now by society you know i i
think that you know you're a good kid
and you only really need three months i
mean it was just a couple of
eight-year-olds you're not that much
older this actually was something that
she said during sentencing at one point
that 18 isn't that much older than eight
so it's not that bad isn't there a
recording of hillary clinton laughing or
something like a child victim or
something like that yes yeah she was she
was laughing it was in court yeah i
would have to go back and look at the i
think she was she was involved she was
arguing a case in arkansas if i'm
remembering correctly she was definitely
she was defending the race right yeah
yeah um but but this is the thing with
even the people attacking hawley admit
that what judge jackson did was
predicated on this distinction just as
as jack just explained and yet you have
the media george stephanopoulos
literally saying that holly's claims
have been debunked by a fact checker
debunked by a fact checker that's a man
who purports to be an anchor at a
neutral news network saying that it's
been debunked by a fact checker which
completely neutralizes the argument to
the public as though josh hawley is some
insane person who's peddling outright
lies but even the defenders even the
people who are attacking holly are
saying that what he said is accurate
they just say listen there's this
argument in criminal justice reform
circles that you can you really do need
to give lighter sentences in these cases
that the congressional mandatory minimum
is wrong and so is there maybe merit to
that argument i don't know perhaps i
mean it sounds like it if she wants to
make that argument she can run for
congress exactly and she can change the
law because that's how separation of
powers works the legislative body is the
one that's supposed to do that not the
justice and we don't need more judicial
activism on the court and certainly we
don't need judicial activism when it
comes to child pornography you see
what's going on now with the
political report of this democrats are
trying to get joe biden to bypass
congress to push for the progressive
agenda because they know congress is
basically deadlocked
so
it just sounds more and more with these
activist judges
that our traditional legislative system
has failed a long time ago i think most
people agree this approval for congress
is just absolutely in the gutter it's
like record lows
so everyone's just sitting there saying
well
representative democracy for legislation
doesn't work get a judge to just bang a
hammer or get joe biden to sign a paper
well and that's the right point here
because that's exactly why we have these
super bitter supreme court confirmation
battles it's because the legislative
branch has kicked the can to the
judiciary into the executive because
they no longer function as the
legislative branch should 100 yeah it's
it's actually really really scary i mean
when was the last time that congress
declared war
right world war ii right yeah
1941
wow
it's scary
following pearl harbor right so i think
the ninth
yeah i mean the like we take for granted
how actually dysfunctional our system is
like obviously we know it's
dysfunctional but we take for granted
how deep the dysfunction is and how like
actually foundational fundamental it is
to the way we operate as a country yeah
when we started the country there's a
bunch of private sector dudes bunch of
and their wives who we really know any
much about but they they basically got
together and started a new government
and it's like i look at this poorly run
government with a bunch of bureaucrats
they're in there for life
i don't i don't know if it's salvageable
i want to be the guy that's like i want
to preserve the the republic but it's i
i was telling you earlier
from the the romance of the three
kingdoms he was obsessed with restoring
the government and he just couldn't it
was a failed attempt but the reason for
this is that the left understood a
generation ago right and the right is
only starting to kind of understand what
happened that their
policy prescriptions would not
you know prevail at the ballot box so if
they could find a bureaucratic or
judicial fix for it then they would go
through that way so they get their
legislation from the bench and you've
seen so many of these social
conservative issues or just social
issues in general be decided through
supreme court cases oh burgerfell o berg
fell or even wade
i think the quintessential you know kcv
planned parenthood right so these these
are all supreme court cases these are
not this was not the original role of
the supreme court whatsoever and the
idea that
kassanji brown jackson is saying this
sort of stuff she's actually getting
upset that holly is question calling
these things into question because to
her mind as a a progressive activist
judge she believes that is the role of
the judge to correct what she sees
herself as issues in the law because of
course that's how you correct it that's
what the judiciary is for right the
legislative i mean that withered and
died on the vine years ago exactly yeah
it's it's seeing your it's that is baked
into the role as people see it on the
left that like of course of course
you're offering these corrections that's
what you exist to do and it's a huge
disconnect between left and right but
it's also just a huge disconnect between
the left and the constitution
well i don't think they much care about
the constitution oh no certainly no
regarding like recovering the republic
uh you had mentioned that if we were
going to do that it would be like we
take the pieces of it that work and then
create new things or or strip away
things that are broken like are there
specific things you'd like to keep and
are the specific ones well i mean i i
think that congress obviously so
congress abrogated its role
um of sovereignty a long long time ago
right and so you know something you know
people talk about term limits but
certainly something needs to be done
with terms for congressmen i think
that's i i don't know if term limits are
the right thing because you know if you
introduce term limits then lobbyists are
just going to run things even more than
they do now right so term limits aren't
necessarily the answer but you've also
got an issue in the executive because
the executive and yarvin writes about
this um
where the executive branch has
essentially under and this was this is
very wilsonian wilson was very clear
about doing this you know growing what
he called the you know essentially the
leviathan right this this sort of the
organic state was what he called it um
we call it the administrative state or
the permanent state the bureaucracy the
civil service so this idea that the
academy
and the ivory the ivory tower of the ivy
league would make decisions and then the
executive kind of
responds to that through these
independent agencies and the bureaucracy
is actually running the government and
so congress the congress is there to
just kind of rubber stamp those
decisions and this is where you get you
know a dr anthony fauci from because he
comes up not through
he's not an elected official nobody ever
voted for this guy he's the most
powerful bureaucrat in all of washington
or he certainly was during the height of
the pandemic his pronoun he would go on
tv literally making pronouncements that
would decide what your child could do in
a local school yeah right from dc this
was the op complete opposite of how our
system is supposed to work and yet we
all went along with it the best was the
double masking cycle where he got asked
you know romney still does that double
mask gosh romney still doubles souchie
got asked about double masking and they
were like isn't it common sense that two
masks would be good he's like yes of
course two masks would be good and then
he comes out later having to no no no
there's no advice saying you should do
it and then the cd the cdc comes out and
says yeah you should double mask like
the idea of double masking just came
from him off the cuff saying it makes
sense to do right someone heard him say
it and then typed it in and pressed
enter and then all of a sudden everybody
was doing it and by the way masks are
bad and they're taking masks away from
our first responders and that's of
course that's what fouchy and the cdc
and actually basically our entire
federal government was saying and again
these people do not understand and they
have not yet reckoned with the level of
distrust that exists in the public but
the big thing is not only do they have
to like reckon with that they have to
not see it as just abject bigotry right
like this is anybody who disagrees with
me is an idiot toothless rube bigot they
have to understand actually why people
distrust them and understand that the
blame lies with them but that is what
they will absolutely never do well that
was the point i i mentioned earlier
where someone tweeted you know it's time
to remind everybody that brett kavanaugh
was credibly accused by christine blasey
ford and republicans didn't care and
it's like no it's because it was made up
it didn't happen why you wouldn't need
to put the word credibly in front of it
if it was legitimate and it was like 30
years ago her own friends that she
didn't remember it didn't even didn't
even know it was brett and they're
trying to make it seem like yeah let me
just tell you man representatives
remember squeezing squeeze yeah let me
let me just let me just
say naughty words i'm sorry for a moment
let me yes the calendar beers beers
babes
they accused a federal judge of being
party to gang rapes plural excuse me not
just they jake tapper jake tapper this
paragon of we're supposed to believe
that he's the most uh you know right
down the line just calling balls and
strikes he had who on air right michael
avenatti
and julie setwick was the client at the
time come on accusing brett kavanaugh at
the time a federal judge and going up
for the highest court in land accused
him of being a member of a gang rape
uh
you know you know
they were during high school pages of
the new yorker what did they say like on
air they would line up outside of a room
with like a woman inside and they would
go in and just you know
take turns
that's insane there's there's no
evidence for anything like that and and
no no sane person would believe such a
ridiculous story
but you know what man they just keep
saying it so i have to wonder how many
people actually believe at this point
what they keep saying but and this is a
point that i've made about the riots in
the summer of 2020 and i think it's a
mistake the right makes sometimes is
that like we just are like oh crazy
people etc etc but people rioting in
2020 have been told for their entire
lives
so i was born in 1993 but even people
younger than me they have been told
their entire lives that they live in a
country that is dripping with racism
systemic racism that is evil and they've
been told this from every institution
sexism racism all of these things are
institutional their institutions are
telling them that and so what do you
expect is going to happen in this
country you have to find a way to sort
of like penetrate that audience make
that argument reasonably because people
have been indoctrinated to the point
where they believe and i think
reasonably so if all of your
institutions are telling you this for
years and years and years everyone
everyone is telling you this oprah's
telling you this your teachers are
telling you this it's coming from
everyone i mean yeah you might riot i
mean it's it's
not right but you can understand the the
sort of impetus for it the party told
you to reject the evidence of your eyes
and ears it was their final most
essential command and if all others
accepted the lie which the party imposed
if all records told the same tale then
the lie passed into history and became
truth george orwell yeah
that's why i just love it when joe
biden's like i was in a secure meeting
with the military officer said there's
going to be a new world order and
they're like that didn't happen that's a
conspiracy right so you can you actually
see it now it's it's like it's like they
it's like somebody gets on the phone
right and calls up and says oh you've
got to get the fact checkers out you
know someone so effective right now the
new york times right so the fact
checkers that's actually if you
understand the npc meme the non-player
character meme so a fact check is
actually just a software upgrade for the
npcs that you have to push out every
time someone short circuits the false
reality short circuits the simulation
they cut right so it's a patch that has
to be up pushed out every time one of
the npc's comes into contact with actual
reality oh right so anytime that joe
biden comes out and says oh by the way
there's a new world order and i was just
talking to the secret military about
this in this meeting they have to push
out
just so you know or you know josh hawley
comes up and says hey how come you were
given all these uh you know child porn
traffickers these you know
these light sentences whoa whoa whoa we
have to put out a factor and if you
notice and lydia you were even talking
about this earlier that in the fact
checks right
all the fact checks admitted that holly
was correct yeah they did but they just
box reason yeah you wrote that but they
they try to explain it away
and yet they label it as a fact check
and it never once says fact check true
because it was this is they just say
it's been fact checked i included this i
did a segment earlier on the joe biden
new world order thing and there's a
website called logically that is a fact
checker and they said you know uh
ukrainian mp passively mentioned a new
world order triggering widespread
conspiracies it was taken out of context
and here's what they did it was an
amazing
it was actually i shouldn't say amazing
it was amazing that they attempted to
pull this off they said the new world
order conspiracy theory is very similar
to the great reset and the great reset
conspiracy is just wrong to the
ukrainian mp was not talking about any
kind of great reset and i'm like yes she
wasn't she literally said new world
order but they just did this leap frog
where it's like did the ukrainian mp
discuss a conspiracy about a great reset
false while she did say she's fighting
for a new world order she did not talk
about a great reason that's the game
they play you're right they are both
similar in the extent that they're both
the explicit ambitions of the global
elite so if these people are lying to
you and we know they've lied to us about
kavanaugh we know they've lied to us
about
russiagate we
can see that they're lying to us in real
time about judge jackson yet we're told
that we have to believe every single
utterance they make about what's
happening in ukraine thousands of miles
away where we don't have direct contacts
unless you're going to these places like
telegram
like you know using vpns getting other
places having to translate it to
actually find out what's going on on the
ground yet we're just about to take that
all as true well the basically the
country expo experienced a soft coup
when woodrow wilson was president when
the federal reserve was formed and they
took control and it's been and they lied
about it we didn't know people didn't
know about it till 15 years ago and then
the internet broke out and loose change
came out you start to realize the
federal reserve and the prince
they lied the whole time this whole
organization has been they pulled the
wool over the american people's eyes to
print their money and take their their
sons to war
so check this out we talked about the
value of a nickel on the show a couple
weeks ago and we read somewhere that it
was like a nickel is 75 percent what i
think copper and 25 nickel and because
nickel is skyrocketing and like actual
metal that the value of a nickel is
actually up the value of a nickel right
now is actually 10 cents
now you can't destroy currency but we're
in this weird time where the legal
currency of the nickel is worth less
than what the actual medal is worth yeah
and so
good luck buying nickels no no no no
joke
go online and try and get nickels for
your business it's it's no wonder there
was a coin coin shortage during covet
because people were probably hoarding
all of their nickels because it's just
the the nothing i forgot why i brought
this up what were we talking about just
a moment ago nickel man let's go deep oh
about the federal reserve oh right right
right right the federal reserve i'm just
thinking about how currency became
completely nonsensical it used to be
that you you'd have silver dimes nickels
and quarters were made of specific
specific metals that had value and and
you knew that a quarter was a specific
amount of that metal
now
nothing makes sense pennies are made of
like zinc copper plated copper-plated
zinc but nickels for some reason still
have nickel but now nickels through the
roof so that's not going to make sense
for much longer the federal reserve at
some point i'm just i'm looking at these
news reports about how the government
was like we hereby order all people to
give their gold to the government just
think about when it was like 1933 right
yeah was it
when when they were like you have to
turn all of your gold over
imagine the government coming your house
and saying you have to give us all your
money
like hey putin invaded ukraine you have
to give us everything you own yeah no no
jokes that's worth the wait people were
just like yep did you see this um hitler
was about i'm just seeing somebody come
across that uh this thing that tucker
had tonight about the fbi and kbj's
nomination interesting so
apparently tucker got an email that went
out
uh internally with the fbi in their la
office that the l the fbi is la women's
and black affairs committee held
a
nomination party
for katanji brown jackson
the invitation reads lots of celebrating
the party is set for march 23rd so
that's tomorrow and
in a conference christy coons johnson
the assistant director in charge of the
la field office is the featured speaker
so they're actually holding nomination
parties for a partisan
political appointee
of the president united states in the
fbi's office did you hear that they were
they they recently changed the name to
uh fbdi the federal bureau of democratic
investigations oh
right no no the fbi is totally neutral
totally do not take sides
i
a w h r the uh federal bureau of
democratic investigations and we hate
republicans well it turns out we're all
wrong
because we live in a republic no no no
yes no we're all republicans because
we're all irredeemable bigots oh yeah i
mean i think literally we're all we're
all living a republic so we're all right
yes yes but i think except as stephen
marsh pointed on the show i'm a true
country is a multicultural democracy and
the other half is a constitutional
republican multicultural democracy of
republicans that's actually a great
point yeah
doesn't believe
or even acknowledge the constitutional
republic right um i remember you know
talking to people
who had gone like to public school you
know a friend of mine when i was you
know still working they would say well
you know did you know that we're
actually not a democracy and i look at
them like yeah i mean obviously right
you know how could you not know that but
they're like but my whole life i was
taught the united states is a democracy
and we need to be a democracy so we need
to get rid of this constitution thing
that's what they're taught whoa who was
that
was it a friend of mine growing up oh
okay but had been through this
completely separate educational track
than i had been through um i was all
catholic school she was all
um you know public high school public
grade school and
like was a very upset and emotional over
the fact
that she found out later on that
actually in fact we were a
constitutional republican i went through
a phase where i really disliked the um
the house of representatives just as an
institution and i thought they were
getting bribed i mean i still don't like
that they're bribed
targets what
get rid of the house of representatives
and michael is like that's going a
little too far in um i went through a
phase where i just i drank water to
survive
oh yeah me too i'm still in that face
[Music]
i like the function of the republic just
that there's a stop gap between the the
citizens and then the
legislators uh but i don't think they
need to be people i think it could be
like or organized mechanically with like
smart contracts and things right because
the people are just too vulnerable it's
a vulnerability or a system they get
bribed
and even if they have term limits the
new ones are going to come in and get
bribed bribe
yeah
they're going to keep getting bribed
but you know i wonder if it's um
many of these members of congress just
don't know they have no principles
so they're simply looking at what gets
me elected the principle is power is it
right yeah it's fascistic right across
the board i don't care if they're it's
majority of republicans save maybe like
the freedom costs caucus a few
republicans almost all of the democratic
party just basically are like all that
matters is power
that's it well mitch mcconnell it's the
mitch mcconnell governing philosophy
it's not about any ideological agenda
it's about maintaining power for the
republican party and that is great for
the lobbyists it's great for the
politicians it's great for that class of
people but if you don't do anything with
that power it completely is telling that
you actually have no who's voting for
this no but this this is actually ram
too this is actually what is confounding
a lot of our policy makers when it comes
to russia because they say well we're
going to go after the oligarchs because
we assume that the oligarchs control
russia the same way they control the
united states right so they think well
in the united states if we just went
after the mega donors then obviously the
politicians would have to do what we
want so they tried to craft their russia
policy based on how the united states
government works but that's not how the
kremlin works and that's not how like
vladimir putin doesn't answer to his
oligarchs they answer to him it's
completely separate from the way the
united states works so when you look at
the way that they're lashing out at
russia it's actually more relevatory in
how the united states system works
because they assume that's how you can
put pressure on the kremlin because
that's how you would put pressure on the
president united states on the congress
on the senate super shorts and that's
what they did in afghanistan too they
set up an american style government and
then when they pulled out the american
style people
it's called the liberal world order the
tribal council no no it is the cfr us
the cfr space website that i pulled up
the cfr website pulled up the council on
foreign relations said the world bank
and the international monetary fund are
how they implement their liberal world
economic order so you go to these
countries and say
we're basically like it's a bribe
essentially we're going to give you
money for development we're giving this
big loan but that means these countries
become beholden to their debt holders it
rapidly modernizes a country it's good
for a lot of people who live there you
know the standard of living skyrockets
but now the countries behold into who
holds there i think chile is going
through that right now their standard of
living just exploded in the last 20 or
30 years but right then you've got
coca-cola and then you've got countries
that reject it like belarus syria
libya
iraq under saddam afghanistan obviously
a variety of reasons north korea for a
variety of reasons and so all of those
countries are there for evil and they
must be destroyed
let's go to super chats it's time if you
have not already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and go to timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only podcast
coming up at about 11 p.m or so and as a
member you will get access to that
website now i've seen some super chats
and comments from people who are saying
there's weird issues happening with
their membership
yes i apologize about this this has to
do with the way paypal works and it is
an issue for us so we've been i don't
know if i should say too much but we're
working on an alternative system
from companies of people you know and
love that i want to say too much tim
coyne because we're trying to create a
more resilient system it's in line with
what a lot of companies are doing
finding alternative ways to secure
memberships and payments if you're
having an issue just email members at
timcast.com and we will get to you we're
not a very large company but we're
growing so it may take us you know a few
days but we're trying and i apologize if
you if if if there's issues we can't get
to but uh we're trying to create a new
membership system so it will only like
if you're already a member you don't
have to worry about anything some people
are dealing with this issue which is
through paypal
you might have to like re-sign up but
very soon we're gonna have a really
exciting announcement and it will you
know be it's gonna be awesome so you're
gonna you're gonna love it it's in line
with a lot of what like the daily wires
been up to in terms of building culture
and parallel economies and making making
our companies more resilient so stay
tuned for that and again apologies for
the issues that people are experiencing
we work very hard we are about 30
employees maybe soon you know we'll be
very very big with your help as members
so be a member let's read some super
chats
all right i really like this one um
raymond g stanley jr says black hole sun
won't you come wash away the rain huh
yes
the physical they're all just
soundgarden fans they're not yeah
soundgarden fans that's right well so
here we go the physicality challenge
chris
so tim cast fell to russian propaganda
which uses the same methods as the left
when labeled maga people as nazis
ukraine is not a nazi country putin
started the war in 2015 2014 by invading
crimea
it sounds like a comment from somebody
and with all due respect i don't think
you watch this show i think maybe you
caught an episode and then you put that
because i think anybody who watches this
knows that we very much have like been
heavily critical of putin heavily
critical of the annexation of crimea and
the don bess region and his invasion but
pointing out facts about one battalion
and questioning why people in the united
states would support the battalion when
they've overtly opposed those same
ideologies before that's all reality i
don't think it's fair for the super
chatter to frame it as if we've said
that ukraine is a nazi country there's a
nazi battalion in there that's clearly
someone who just like never said that
put in that comment without actually
listening to the show
jm says you guys should try to get the
lead singer from muse on they just
dropped a banger of a song and also i
love you ian keeps spreading those good
vibes matthew bellamy i am a huge fan
but uh i'm not sure if they're you know
if muse is like woke left or whatever
well based on their songs i don't think
they care for the government well yeah
but i think something happened where i
think glenn beck used a song of theirs
yeah it used to be his intro was muse
yeah and then they came out and said
they're like they denounced him and said
the right stole conspiracy the left used
to do it and i'm just like yeah
uh muse i can sum up muse it's one of my
favorite all-time favorite bands i can
play a ton of their songs on guitar but
um the way i describe muse is i love you
but the government is taking over yeah
that's like the gist of all of their
songs like sometimes they actually write
songs that have both those elements yeah
it's great you know and i'm just like
how do you make a song about government
authoritarianism and you loving someone
i still remember nihilism before they
got big
they actually played my my college oh
really like years and years ago at
temple university and so we got to go
and i mean they were they were big going
back into like the early 2000s dude
early 2000s yeah and it but i mean the
show itself was like a couple hundred
people maybe whoa and it was so great
wow so great man i've been a i've been a
fan of muse for a long time they're a
great man yeah and i like how they sing
about how the government is bad you know
it's just it's pretty good it's
performed in 1994 i love you yeah but a
lot of the people who who sang about why
the government is bad neil young um now
believe that corporations are good
what was up with bad religion writing
that pro alt-right song that was so
weird did you guys hear that one no
it was i i don't know if they were
trying to be tongue-in-cheek like it was
critical of the alt-right but it's
literally it's called the kids r
alt-right
and the song has you know it's it's pro
alt-right i don't understand well
there's something like there's one who's
song the kids are all right right right
they're making it they're like the bad
religion wrote a song called the kids
are alt-right
and in the song he's basically just
advocating for the alt-right whoa
i don't yeah which i don't understand so
it's the anthem of the [ __ ] i'm
seeing that matt bellamy went on with
alex jones multiple times
i'm curious now i'm gonna check it out
really yeah i'm gonna look it up now
open it up yeah
the kids are all right it's talking
about uh nazism in germany like they're
talking about pure hearts race on a
crystal night like that's crystal
knocked as well yes yes yes but they
don't like the song doesn't insult them
it praises them oh that's the weird oh
yeah you're right join the party the
kids are all right everybody needs
somebody so join the party it's like
are they trying to be trying to be
tongue-in-cheek because
there may be a bunch of kids who just
don't understand you are singing the
praises of all these people right it's
probably an anthem against like
conformity or is it one of those or is
it one of those straussian things we're
like no no we're we're against it even
though we were higher you know like
satire let's uh let's read some more but
it's no set they want you to think it's
satire but all right
hannah carter says tim can my daughter's
book get a shout out please she's nearly
ate autistic and wants to be the next
beatrix potter i'm very proud of her the
tale of the red squirrels by a carter on
amazon thanks so much cute yes nice work
love that author t-a-i-l
all right
make 1984 fiction again says the first
15 minutes of this show you described
destiny aka steven bonnell the third how
did we describe him what were we
referring to
i'm not sure we've had him on the show
before i think i thought it was actually
i thought it was great were we talking
about him where it was yesterday we were
talking about it the other day we talked
briefly about him because people were
praising him i think it was uh lewis was
saying he's he's someone on the left
who's willing to look at the facts and
call out the left if he's right yeah and
he did that with kyle i think a lot of
people are coming from their past with
like he was probably raised in that
environment but like but they have the
clear mind and they want to know the
truth but they're just they're bringing
all their baggage so they got to kind of
shed it away as they learned that's how
i like destiny he's a sweet guy yeah hey
tim before i move on i just want to say
that i went to band tv and it says alex
jones inspired matt bellamy to write
uprising
is that true don't know is alex jones
claiming that or is matthew i don't know
i'm going to find out when was the last
time matthew bellamy appeared on 2006 it
was a long i know this was written in
2020 yeah so alex jones used to be kind
of considered like a part of the left
right right because
go look at paul joseph watson's early
youtube videos you know what they're
about
their anti-police brutality videos well
that's why it was prison planet right um
opposing government authority right
oppression
you know all that stuff that's why if
you watch the movie um a scanner darkly
with keanu reeves so it used to be this
like hipster thing to be like a secret
fan of alex jones like they would say oh
he's quirky but he's against bush so we
like him and alex jones has that cameo
where he like drives by with a bull horn
no no he gets arrested or he gets
arrested yeah yeah and then keanu reeves
is like walking down whoa that's that
rotoscope movie yeah it's rotoscope yeah
that's a good movie it's a good movie i
like it
i like it all right um let's see we got
here
dennis
gregerson says is the senator from
hawaii presley going to ask the nominee
if she has ever been charged or
suspected of harassment apparently she
asks every nominee or so she says uh
maisie hirono yeah is that her yeah yeah
maisie hirono is she gonna ask that
crazy amazing yeah i don't know probably
not because again you're making yourself
vulnerable to accusations of bigotry and
sexism
which god forbid maisie joreno ever ever
approached that line right all right
flufferboy2004 says oh boy do you think
the daily wire will start producing
music jack stop sending in comments um
that wasn't that i was logged in to the
other guy
that was an older
you know the the approach we've had from
for like the cultural stuff has been
we we've done three we've done four
things the daily wires doing movies and
they want to do shows and i actually
have a really good idea for a joint show
with the daily wire and i was like mid
show i literally hit up dallas and i'm
like i got an idea that's great so um
we've been talking to them they want to
do a show but i think i have the perfect
show and i'm not going to say anything
just yet but we've done we've done a few
things we've done first we did tales
from the inverted world which is
murder mystery paranormal investigations
and the new series we're working on
apparently is absolutely off the wall
part season two the next book we're
doing in the next series of podcasts so
shane cashman who's our investigator and
writer he went down to the georgia
guidestones and was like checking it out
and he has like pictures there's like
people dying and he's he went down there
to look for the lost confederate gold so
there's like ghosts there's apparently
threatening
i can't say too much because i don't
know about the legal issues but there
are threats you know people do not want
this investigation so this is not overly
political it's like fun mystery you know
true crime-ish murder people are dying
it's fun so then we've also done pop
culture crisis which uh subscribe to pop
pop culture crisis on youtube this is
pop culture show with you know the crew
it's hosted by brett dasovich
we've done um was i gonna say the other
one was we have chicken city
of course chicken city is just a live
stream of chickens and we're really good
by the way we got monetized so now you
can super chat and play sounds but we're
gonna be building that up chicken city
is also great by the way if you have
pets that stay home by themselves
because pet like dogs will just sit and
stare at that fruit
but we're also doing music and so i feel
like the daily wires go on this
traditional route where they're doing
movies and shows and stuff and we've
gone more of the the digital
with like youtube channels like cast
castle and pop culture crisis and so i
feel like
you know the i i wanna i wanna see what
they're up to because we're very much
interested in doing shows but that's not
our area and so we talked with them and
they were like we'd love to do a show
with you so i have an idea for a show
that i think is a really good idea for a
show yeah i think another one you're
talking about i think x-files
but i can't say too much and that's the
realm where you need the sort of
creativity and innovation because the
music industry much to the chagrin of
some huge artists and for some good
reasons actually has been democratized
so there are a lot of like really
heterodox artists making music that you
can find on spotify because the barrier
to entry has been lowered significantly
and that still doesn't exist in like
movie theaters or on cable tv
whereas tv shows that's where you
actually really need to have the
production value and you need to have
the viewership yeah let's read this one
kevin billa says how will hollywood
react when the daily wire makes a movie
that is so oscar-worthy they have to be
nominated or win they won't who cares
about the oscars
it won't get nominated but it will make
a splash and change the world
all right dragon lady says tim tim tim
in your first episode today the the next
generation episode of the picard proving
data sentience is measure of a man not
make thank you for the correction the
one with the romulan grandfather was the
drum head thank you for the correction
sins of the father was about wharf's
family great freedom tunes today love
your fouchy uh yes i said make of a man
it's a measure of a man and i said i'm
not sure what the episode is where
they're trying to hunt down the romulan
spy because the guy's got a rhyming
grandfather but i thought i was like
it's not since the father i don't think
and thank you for the correction but um
i posted a clip from the next generation
and for anybody who hasn't seen star
trek have you watched the next
generation no no you need
yes you have uh and everyone else you
must because there's there's probably a
lot of people who are surrounded by
losers see that's exactly
this is exactly what i'm going to point
out right now is the problem you don't
watch star trek because it's like star i
don't like star wars star wars is
fantasy
magic powers star trek is watching a
classically liberal society
technologically advanced and captain
picard is a role model and as a
fictional character patrick stewart's
portrayal
absolutely life-changing as a kid to see
this
there's there's a scene i posted because
we were watching it before the show
posted it on twitter data's an android
he creates uh he creates a daughter he
creates a new version of himself it's
the only he's the only android in
existence so the federation is an
admiral and he's like we have to seize
it because it's too too powerful of of a
technology technological advancement
and so he tells data to give up his kid
and data says you know this is my child
and i have a duty to my child and the
the admiral says then i'm ordering you
to give up your your child and then
picard says belay that order the admiral
goes i beg your pardon data and then
picard goes data stand your ground
and then the admiral says you are
risking your command and your career and
picard smirks and says there comes a
time when men of good conscience must
disobey orders that are unjust or
something that affect and he says
for this you know this uh to compel a
man to give up his child to the state
not while i'm captain and i'm just like
clapping classical classical libertarian
liberalism classical civil
libertarianism all of those values
telling telling your commanding officer
that i will sacrifice my career my
command and everything to defend one
person's right rights and their freedoms
and liberties oh man
that show is just gold and i wish one of
many episodes where in real life picard
would immediately be relieved of command
right yes yes yeah obviously the worst
captain in starfleet everyone knows well
cisco is by far the best commander he
was great um uh um what's what's the one
where he stages the false flag you know
i'm talking about with the kardashians
yeah yeah yeah i can't remember it but
um but i will say i know right to to the
writer's credit you're right about him
being relieved of command in the episode
before anything can happen there's an
emergency call and they rush to the lab
where data's daughter is dying and so
the admiral is then desperately trying
to save data's daughter and says i'm
sorry and that's what prevents it from
escalating beyond picard i think what
part of what made that show like in any
real navy picard would be really i mean
he's violated
theatrically trained actor he had
massive stage presence and knew how to
project the entire stone stage so he was
the abandoned performing artist
not just his rank yeah like you look at
jane wayne i thought she had such a weak
voice that like if she's down the hall
yelling commanding orders it's like
well she's just sitting where you have
it
you know
i thought i thought they they weren't
isn't it they didn't command their
voices the way that picard did isn't
today william shatner's birthday oh
happy birthday 1991. all of the 90s era
star trek shows were good voyager just
was like a c plus they were rocked was
it i didn't see any of them after i i
tried
i'm an enterprise fan
i'll i'll i will it's not a bad show die
on that hill i wanted to like excuse me
it is not just a prequel it is all so
far in the future yeah i think i found
out that alex jones was not in a scanner
darkly but in waking life no he's in
both he's in both they're both richard
linklater films
all right let's read some more we got
kristen himmel says tim we need to stop
supporting the corporations that hate
our values there's an app called public
sq public square public square that is
fighting against this and has a
marketplace of over 4 000 businesses
that support conservative values you
should interview the ceo mike michael
selfer so i actually know about public
square um recently got acquainted with
them
um it's it's amazing so it's basically
like i kind of describe it as like next
door but for companies that don't hate
you
so you can lock you can download it on
you know whatever platform you have um
they're both on apple and android and
you can go in if you just want something
like hey i want to go to a restaurant
that's all locally sourced you can do
that or you can find whatever service
you want you can plug in your address
you can find ones that are in your area
it and if you are like someone who wants
to be listed on something like that you
can just you know put up a thing for
free public square is actually really
really cool when it comes to that stuff
and this is
just something that obviously should
exist
the wrong writer says a free man thinks
rules are followed a slave thinks rules
are enforced
did you guys know that in the since the
new york times took over wordle
you can't put the word slave in
i did not it's scandalous so if so for
those that know what word allows you to
say you get a five-letter word
to that uh that comment the slave one no
no the guy's the guy oh yeah well what's
your response my response is the
shopping cart theorem
yeah you're familiar with the shopping
cart theorem that
well there's there's this shopping cart
test but what's the test theory the idea
that the idea being that
um there are people who will put the
shopping cart back and there are people
who will not put the shopping cart back
you suffer no penalty for not putting
the shopping cart back
you will incur no no you know fee or
fine no one's ever going to come and you
know chase you down and indict you for
this and yet you do it because you are
an upstanding member of society this is
the rule however there are people who
will not put the shopping cart back and
they are the ones who
because of them we require law
enforcement you know what hold on
what you're missing from that is that
the the shopping cart test is it's a
minor inconvenience to you with no
reward right but also no penalty but
it's the right thing to do right to
return the shopping cart to the corral
however you go to stores and what do you
see shopping carts are everywhere strong
about and that's our society i worked at
a grocery store and was the bad boy in
cashier and all that did the and uh i
would collect the carts i always take
the carts back it feels good to do a
good deed for another person it does
especially when you i like um right but
you that makes you efficient that means
you're a good citizen if you can give a
little and that other person gets a lot
out of it that's a valuable trade for
you even if you're never going to see
that person but ian not everyone in
society
believes the way you believe or i
believe
because they are not good citizens and
because of people who are willing to
forego that inconvenience as a detriment
to society that's what then necessitates
the rules and the enforcers of the rules
okay well that's the john adams if men
were angels right now
but
and that is it's sort of a cliche but
sorry libertarians yeah yes
joshua leblanc says about time emily's
on the show federalist radio hour is
great and she killed it on rising cool
well thanks that's so nice of you is the
first time you're on yes first time i
was on i appreciate the shout out for
federalist radio hour because it's a
it's a daily show like what you guys do
and you guys know that's a lot of work
it is oh yeah
when you do your show what time is it i
mean i pre-tape some i do some the same
day so it's just kind of a constant
grind but you guys know that does it
always go up at the same hour every day
no we just i mean it usually goes up
around 5 p.m okay yeah cool yeah
all right justin williams says do you
think the convention of states will be a
way to save the government from itself
absolutely not no why is that no and i
just think there's so many of these sort
of do nothing um things out there that
sound good on paper but at the end of
the day if you're not addressing what
what emily brought up this idea of our
judiciary being completely out of
control or this also this idea of the
executive
and the the tie between the executive
and the academy that if you're not
addressing any of that stuff directly
then you're just it's just not going to
go and even something as substantive as
calling a convention of the states which
would require a herculean sort of public
effort to even make happen you're still
going to be basically tinkering around
the margins until you deal with what
jack just said yeah yeah like the
president could just be like no we're
going to override anything the
convention said
and the administrative state i mean we
just talked about it i mean look at what
the education department does and what
you just said about the fed
yeah right this is the century in the
making more yeah or yeah potentially
more yeah
all right explant x says ian did you get
the book i sent you the book of
antithesis it's an occult grimoire of
real magic for dnd dungeon masters it's
now available in the us web store from
the
lamentations of flame princess don't
mess with the cult don't love it don't
do it do not mess with the cold i don't
know absolutely not i've been wanting to
screw around with such things i've been
wanting to do a dnd
based on
like dnd fine sure i don't know but i'm
all into demonology i think my story
made them evil i wanted to do a dnd
based on modern politics so it's like
running for a campaign instead of
fighting dragons and so it's it's what
they did with uh podesta and the you
know uh this is yeah they came up with
the game for the 2020 election right so
i'm like i would love to play a game
like that in filmics ever since i read
that they war game didn't they have
trump like uh declared martial law or
something it got it got nuts it would be
hilarious it would be like you know ian
could play as hillary and he'd be like
i'm gonna run in 2028 and like you know
it looks like skeletor critical success
critically
i got plus 80 to my role because i'm
familiar with the council on foreign
relations but that would be that would
be hilarious to film we should do that
you should call it the liberal award
order the liberal world order yes
yeah uh seamus can be trump yeah that'll
be fun and then we'll just see how uh we
should do that for 2024. that'd be fun
yeah yeah we should do it that'd be
great
all right let's see we got
elijah jay kramer says this group is
always high on free speech and i think
all would agree it's a cornerstone of
our republic why then do i not see any
of you on gab it's the only true free
speech platform i'm on gab i posted on
gab last night
i don't post on gab all that often i
don't it's tough because you got to go
to every network and post on every
network separately facebook twitter
and so my tweets auto post to mine so
that's been simple for me i mean i and i
understand the necessity like i post on
twitter because it's it's helpful to
sort of amplifying the message but i
actually and i talked to at the time the
ceo of parlor about this you cannot just
replicate these evil secular platforms
without changing the addictive
functionings of them right so like you
cannot just come up with gab or parlor
or rumble all of which i think are great
sort of test balloons or rumble at least
i think is a good test balloon and i
think parlor was as well that sort of
are saying well look there is a market
for this do it better and you will
attract customers and you capitalists
can take your money but we can't just do
that if we're replicating the the
mechanisms that keep people sick and
addicted and depressed on different
places and so i'm already on one of
those i don't feel the need to to do it
more than once
yeah i think of rumble by the way if
they're able to integrate rumble with
sort of some of the stuff we're talking
about with like daily wire and streaming
and some of these things that is gonna
because rumble is obviously already
fantastic but
that you would get that integration
going that would take you to next summer
i think rumble needs a kind of like
twitter yeah yeah microblogging function
it would make them huge
yeah it's hard though that's what
youtube forgot to do
twitter function in the early days with
locals the challenge is yes but the
challenge is when it gets too cluttered
right so a lot of people tell me minds
is too cluttered yeah it's like trying
to do everything at once you got into
lots of buttons and stuff once you
figure it out it's phenomenal but
there's just a high learning curve yeah
all right let's read this secretary
tenebrous says quick psa if anybody else
hasn't done it a major tornado just went
through the lower ninth ward of new
orleans major damage and loss of life
they don't have enough ambulances man
sorry to hear i hope everybody
actually uh my uh
my
my producer at human events daily
actually she's from louisiana and she
was saying that her family got a tornado
warning earlier today wow so yeah i hope
they're good that's
awful
all right
wicked lis says a series you should do
tim and maybe with sheamus is create
cartoons explaining how government works
aka old cartoon i am just a bill sheamus
actually has a show it's common sense
soapbox i think yeah
that he does a lot a lot
yeah with with fe basically does that
yeah it's great
all right
hamrod says dan crenshaw is not
establishment guys youtubers are
what is that
was that a reference to something no i
think we're like is that sarcastic maybe
we invited dan on the show and he said
yes and then he said no yeah
not surprising i mean i think it's
trying to make this point that youtubers
who decry cancel culture rightfully so
are in some ways very much like they
have become very powerful that doesn't
make you establishment uh and that's a
huge mistake i think people make
although it's an easy one to make if
your establishment you're beholden to
all of this this infrastructure that
includes special interests um and if
you're a youtuber that's really powerful
i mean you have to maintain the trust of
your audience and that's a very
different thing
all right ryan brown says if you think
the fourth turning is real then look at
the rensberg prophecies it's very
detailed and geopolitically accurate
from 100 years ago
interesting
you know what's fascinating is the uh
the story of baron trump from the 1800s
the underground um
what is it the underground journey or
something it's got to be fake i don't
know yeah what is it yeah i know like it
can't be real can ingersoll lockwood or
whatever was it the name
and apparently the book's real but
someone had to have written it and then
claimed it was from a long time ago my
favorite my favorite um baron trump
conspiracy theory is that um is that
steve bannon is barron trump from the
future sent back to guide his father
well that makes sense it's like it's
called the baron trump novels from 1889.
in the novel hold on in one of the
novels
trump castle on fifth avenue is attacked
by socialist and anarchists from the
lower east side of manhattan that's
actually in the book
this is not real is it so weird they
remained obscure until 2017 when they
received media attention for course they
did perceive similarities there's a meme
of trump from the 1980s
it's the theme just goes donald trump
1980 why do time travelers keep trying
to kill me i'm just a real estate guy
oh i'd love to see people on the lower
east side riot that'd be fun yeah
without locking it they would have
noticed
there we go well sandra and dreamwalker
says star trek deep space nine in the
pale moonlight
boom
tv show boom i just haven't been able to
get into it you guys like deep space
nine did you did you watch this episode
no no watch all of it so i don't know
it's the only star trek uh series where
there's like an actual war yeah so the
federation's like basically losing and
they need to figure out a way to get the
romulans to join their side in this war
so they stage a false flag attack
against the romney yeah that was the
dude it's crazy when i was younger it
felt like too much too political it was
a lot of talking not enough like laser
beams but it's actually it's actually
the opposite
next generation is far more political
than deep space nine deep space nine is
says roddenberry didn't like
interpersonal conflict and so that's why
when you watch tng it's this very like
sanitized culture that no actual like
anyone who served in the military would
ever find anywhere um because he didn't
allow there to be interpersonal conflict
between characters on the ship because
the federation is this enlightened
progressive culture in the way they say
so yeah exactly and versus but there's
also like children on the ship but that
could make some sense i feel strongly
that i am not drunk enough to have this
confidence
and then deep space nine but d space
nine was the first one that came out
after roddenberry died and so probably
wouldn't have allowed it to to come to
pass and it's you know they're on like
the fringes of the federation and that
there's a wormhole and a war takes place
and it's just this like
you know it's this it's this kind almost
emerging of sort of the star wars type
of plot line but in the star trek
universe are they able to open and close
the world
can they open and close the wormhole it
will no it's just open that's no it's
just nervous that's the first episode
are they are they on the other side of
the wormhole too like they have another
outpost over there
well that's that's part of the show yeah
yeah but basically uh a powerful alien
race from a different quadrant is able
to gain access and it's more powerful
than basically all of the typical
you know star trek races you're familiar
with
so
the federation losing they they have a
conversation where like if the romulans
who are long-time enemies of the
federation
would join the federation and the
klingons in the war they could win
and so the romulans are like no we're
going to team up with the dominion
they're going to offer us favorable
deals conquer you guys and then they
have this conversation where they're
like you think that once they conquer us
they're gonna let you they're gonna
spare you and they're like we'll see so
the federation stages a false flag
attack killing a romulan senator blaming
it on the dominion to force them to
enter the war on their side yeah bro
talk about good tv
like this if you're into the stuff we
talk about you will want to watch star
trek the next generation at least and
deep space i think the first one was
great is a little campy i mean it's very
campy by today's standards but powerful
like like leonard nimoy and and
you know chat justin
like if you have questions oh my god if
you have questions about false flags and
like what governments and militaries do
they they wrote a script exploring these
ideas in a great war and why
even you're supposed to like the
federation they're the good guys
that being said that being said while
we're while we're on the subject i
didn't plan to talk about any of this
tonight but the the you know when people
ask me star wars or star trek i always
say that the correct answer is clearly
battlestar galactica
i thought it was good
it was only one season right i mean
there's a new one battle star did it go
on for multiple seasons
it just felt like the same season that
went on too long though no that's
definitely definitely four seconds stars
it started off good and then kind of
it's better than both of them really
we're gonna go to super uh no we're
gonna go to the member segment we've
already gone into projects we're gonna
go we're gonna go to that member segment
so if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show wherever you can it
really really does help and go to
timcast.com become a member
we are going to be doing a major upgrade
with a big announcement i'm really
excited for this um because we are we
are working towards
creating those parallel economies man
and that's one thing we're planning on
doing so we'll we'll mention that what's
happening soon and if you're having
issues just email members at timcast.com
we want to make sure everybody's being
taken care of because these upgrades are
causing some bumps but paypal also has
some issues so i apologize for that but
go to timcast.com we're going to record
that member segment right now for all of
you guys it'll be up at 11. you can
follow the show at tim cast irl you can
follow me at tim cast emily do you want
to shout anything out no just federalist
radio hour and at emily joshinski there
you go uh jacksoba goes to human events
daily and if you want to sleep like joe
biden sleeps through the fourth turning
and head over to mypillow.com and use
promo code poso for up to 66 percent how
long were you sitting on that one uh
literally just three seconds
but i've been sitting on this my pillow
cushion for even longer which is
available that's smooth i like that uh
ian crosslanding crosston.net i do want
to shout out thomas massey for applying
bill hr24
transparency
audit the federal reserve for real
check it out i love how this evening
every single person here has their own
show so you guys are all fully on board
with what we're doing here i appreciate
what all you guys are doing and i had a
great time this evening thank you guys
for coming you guys can follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sour patch lids
we'll see you all at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you